foreign
[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. oh clock
[Music]
hello everybody it's wednesday i almost
said happy friday see it's we've been
doing this for a couple of weeks now and
i'm still thinking that that's just
weird
second week i'm just i'm so confused but
you know change the day
mango said is it really episode 270. i
was thinking about that the other day
because sometimes i forget like what
number the episode is
and when i was doing my notes i
initially typed episode 170 and then i
was like no it's actually 270. holy crap
yeah yeah we've been doing this for
doing a lot for a long time more than
five years at this point yeah because we
started in like the summer of 2016. went
by fast
it really did like i said it's crazy
that's why sometimes like when people
ask me if you've done a show on this or
that it's like i can't really remember
right away then they look at us like
we're crazy
been doing
[Laughter]
and it's like i can't remember like what
all movies we've reviewed i can't
remember like what all topics we've
talked about yeah we lose track we lose
track of the difference between what we
actually did what we talked about doing
that's yeah that's true too
and i think one of the problems too is
that sometimes like particularly with
the true crime cases like sometimes i've
wrote about them for my book yeah um so
i don't remember if i just wrote about
them for my book or if we actually did a
show about it we'll mention a case
inside another case but we didn't focus
on the case that we made yeah because i
think that happens a lot with the
disappearances shows because usually we
do like four or five of those on like
one show so sometimes people be like oh
have you covered like this disappearance
or that and i'm like wait did we yeah
because and sometimes too like
especially on those um i had notes for a
lot more stuff and then we didn't get to
it so that happens to you so yeah 270
episodes
and my brain is just swiss cheese at
this point
because i can't remember [ __ ]
but i know that we haven't done this
topic and i've been wanting to do this
topic for a long time so i was super
jazzed that finally finally because i
kept putting it in the poll and it never
won and then finally at won like
definitively this time and i was like
hooray because i don't want to do this
for a long time because i love this
[ __ ]
it's not a story it really happened but
i made a good move today
by accident
i went down to i went down to the uh to
my bank bank of america was talking to
just a random dude there who was like
handling my account i was asking him
about my credit cards i had to top [ __ ]
off i told him i was buying his house
and they're like well women who you
going through and i told him
he's like but i'm your banker
it's just it's like oh it's her dude is
he getting like jealous yeah yeah
[Laughter]
so
he's like okay well when you find out
what they're offering you come back and
show it to me let's see if i can beat
their deal
and he goes because they i might be able
to give you a more favorable loan
so we'll see
gotta get these banks fighting each
other yeah fighting fighting to give you
money yeah that's that's always good
yeah he's like sometimes what happens is
if you don't go through your own bank or
this and that you go through something
that your homeowner wants they might be
friends and you know maybe they're like
you know would you just let me look at
it
he's like he's like
and i think and i was like going yeah
because he doesn't care who he goes no
he doesn't care as long as he gets the
money he doesn't care who finances it
let me look at it i think i i might be
able to give you a more favorable deal
in in in the in the rates
and i said okay all right just don't say
nothing just when you get it bring it
let me see
don't say nothing you just did though
yeah
i don't care instead of procedure he
owes to [ __ ] 20 properties he doesn't
care who the [ __ ] if when he gets that
money he's happy that's what i mean he's
like you're having fun it wouldn't
really matter like where the money came
from
uh tammy says i have to go back and
rewatch episodes because i forget what
they're all about sometimes yeah same
here and we actually did them
uh grandpa's hammer says of the 270
episodes which one are you the most
proud of ooh that's a hard question oh
[ __ ] um
yeah i mean i was hit i really enjoyed
the satanic panic show both of the ones
that we did um and that was [ __ ] that
was going back to like number two
i probably i don't know i kind of feel
like um
oh man the the [ __ ] dude that was the
dude that was
[ __ ] all the corpses and i lost it
oh yeah that might be my favorite outfit
here in florida
that one i [ __ ] lost that was what we
call it the loving the dead episode it
was about necrophilia yeah where tom
just like quit the show
at the end of it and i was just like i
laughed i wasn't [ __ ] joking either
i can't take the [ __ ] i mean of all the
terrible [ __ ] that we've talked about on
this show that was just that was too far
over the line
he's like i'm out i'm out i started
thinking about it that he was having sex
with that damn mummy
he even gave it a [ __ ] fake [ __ ]
man now he's gonna like don't get
started this early because then you're
just gonna like think about it the whole
thing is look you're thinking about it i
can tell by the look underneath oh man
[ __ ] was in love with this little
young girl
like a fake dug her ass up took her home
he made like a fake [ __ ] out of like a
toilet paper too yeah it wasn't a toilet
paper tube but it was like something
like that
he had her all paper mache and [ __ ] so
you really was just like a [ __ ] paper
face it so he didn't even need her he
could have just made a paper mache dummy
see and i kind of feel like that's
something that we covered on the show
i'm like if that's what he was gonna do
yeah then why did he actually need the
body couldn't he just have something of
hers like a lock of her hair or
something not gross
that could like represent her body
instead of actually having the body and
then covering it with paper mache it was
psychological
i suppose i honestly it's that's gross
as hell but i kind of felt more sorry
for that dude than anything because he
didn't kill her
um
he was just a very very sad messed up
individual you know what i mean he just
like was in love with her and she died
of natural causes and he's like well i'm
gonna go
relief you know you know i'm not saying
it's good he shouldn't have done that
because it's still illegal but he didn't
at least he didn't kill her so you know
uh mango said the first live stream is a
classic but yeah tom freaking out over
loving the dead was so funny i know i
still like laugh like thinking about it
one of these days i'll probably rewatch
it
and that and the more grossed out he got
like the more entertained i became yeah
she can't [ __ ] [ __ ] with me about it
i know because it was so fun it was so
fun that you were getting so disgusted
and i was just i was just trying to make
a gross regret i wasn't i wasn't into it
um i'm not into it either but it's just
funny that you're getting grossed out by
i'm grossed out by it too but not to the
point where i can't like read about it
i was thinking about it and i just was
like
sabrina said the necrophilia episode was
the first one i watched if you guys yet
what an introduction yeah
oh my god that's probably our best one
uh yeah i mean we've done a lot of good
ones i mean there's some that um
that i kind of feel like man i wish i
had covered it like better or something
like that but i don't know i've kind of
learned to let it a lot of that the
lawrence the one about the warrens that
was a good one
yeah we did two of those didn't we
because i think we did a warren's one
and we did like a warren's revisited
that where we covered some cases that we
hadn't covered in the first one i feel
like the warrens one still
um easily like our top viewed episode
and also the one that i get the most
hate mail about
um but not so much anymore because it's
old now but um but i still to this day
like it's weird because the you'd think
the true crime ones that you would get
more abusive comments but the very few
abusive comments are almost always on
the paranormal episodes
and the warren once it's always uh
religious fundamentalists yeah always
but it's weird because i guess people
that are like really really invested in
ghost stories like haunted houses and
stuff like that they really like they
get really really offended when people
like say that maybe it's not ghosts yeah
even more than like they get more
offended than like anybody i'm really
not sure why
yeah and the warrants were hacks
they were on some real cases yeah
but they were they were bullshitting
most of the time yeah
uh mathias tells a joke why did dr
frankenstein hire igor as his assistant
because he had a hunch about him
yeah so look it's like i even have my
bride of frankenstein shirt on
uh
look at this [ __ ] what is she doing
tearing up more books yeah she just
likes to tear up books you guys are not
paying attention to me and also uh she
had to vape she was laying in this chair
because i was sitting in here working
and she was like just laying there for
hours and so tom had to like dump her
out the chair and she's like still mad
yeah she's mad about that
even though we gave her another exact
same chair like right here that she
could sit in and we put her in it she
was like [ __ ] that yeah you chucked me
out of my chair she doesn't understand
what the show is the show is just when
the people talk to the lights yeah and
she's like lights right here we're
talking to these lights and it's just
that's beyonce and you guys are not
talking to me and you guys are not
petting me
she's like so i'm just going to go
around in the background and scratch
everything don't throw a pillow oh my
god look she's tearing it up
she's serious she wants me to go back
there and stop her
she's so funny she like she figured out
like today in the dressing room because
remember i said she figured out how to
like open that lower cabinet and i she
was playing on it like scratching on it
and then like i turned around and she
was gone and i was like wonder if she's
still in there so like i opened it and
she had like gone back in the cabinet it
was like laying back in there and she
was in there for like a really long time
like in the dark i don't know what she's
doing there she's so weird
she's so weird she challenged me to come
get her
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah well you know she's laying down now
she should be cool good girl well for
five minutes until she forgets right
[Laughter]
but yeah so did let's see do we have any
like particular shout outs or anything
that we needed to
talk about in particular before we kind
of get into this oh yeah i was saying
like i have my frankenstein poster back
there too which you know this is
i don't even remember like the first
time because i mean i read frankenstein
in school i think uh as probably most
people did
and
i didn't know i think when i first read
the book i didn't know like the
fascinating story behind it well and i
should say too that and i kind of want
to get into this a little bit
um
is that the
the incidents that led to the writing of
frankenstein
may have also sort of maybe indirectly
led to
later uh an inspiration for dracula as
well
um
which i also i found like really
interesting i think what i find really
interesting about this
historical incident or series of
incidents if you want to call it that is
that
on paper i guess it seems like all of
this like weird unrelated stuff
but it was almost kind of like one of
those weird things where like the
universe kind of all
comes together and like all these
uh varying things happen at one time and
then like the cultural
uh you know
results of it are just like long-ranging
um even though i'm sure they probably
didn't obviously they didn't know that
at the time
this um
this scene here was the beginning of the
goth scene
yeah probably it was yeah well goth is
very rooted in romanticism yeah and then
the horror that they were writing
so this is the very beginning of the
gothic horror and when you hear about
mary shelley and [ __ ] read about some
of the [ __ ] that she said and the weird
[ __ ] she was kind of into and her
husband and
stuff that went down it sounds like goth
kids and they were young
they were young yeah it really does
sound like
it sounds very modern yeah they were
rich kids they lay around get high and
[ __ ] swap wives
[Laughter]
they're teenagers you know and they're
just like free love or like in their 20s
yeah yeah teenagers 20s and swap wives
and get high and smug opium and [ __ ] in
the [ __ ] their parents house and big
old mansions and mary shelley wondering
what it would be like to screw her dad
that kind of weird [ __ ]
yeah i was saying it was really weird
yeah
yeah she well i don't know if i'd call
her weird i mean she was um well i guess
she was she was pretty weird for the
time yeah um
and as all were all of them i mean they
were all considered
uh and here i'm talking about lord byron
uh percy shelly something like that so
they they were kind of like
they were elites in a sense
but
they the ideas that they had were very
very radical for them yeah they were
they were non-conformist big time yeah
and uh they so a lot of society and
stuff like kind of ostracize them for
those very reasons although they were
kind of coming out of the 1700s and a
lot of people are not aware of the fact
that the late 1700s was a sexual
revolution
yeah there have been many going on there
there have been many there was nudism
free love uh just living with like
common law like they're like ben
franklin ben franklin
had a couple wives and i don't think he
was married any of them
yeah yeah you know just they were like
common law wives
and he was a nudist
and uh
would give weird advice to young dudes
it was sound advice really he said you
know these older women are quite
appreciative
yeah you say [ __ ] like that you know if
you're a young man and handsome then
maybe you need to give attention to
these older women go look at the widows
the widows you know go after some of the
cougars yeah they are very appreciative
to young men you know
you said to read between the lines yeah
what he's talking about
he was cool though he's very cool he
seemed like a cool dude yeah hanging out
in the french court
courting all those [ __ ] french girls
and [ __ ] freaking that was how politics
was done in france at that time
politics wasn't business politics was
[ __ ] social activity so you had there
was a scene so you had to
be [ __ ] high up in the social scene
and
he'd walk around with a damn
[ __ ]
raccoon hat on yeah
yeah acting like a damn simpleton
and giving out
you know wisdom from the woods
to impress french people when he was a
city dweller he was just pretending to
be a red deck
he said so
thank you zach
he only wore a coon-skinned hat when he
was in france
funny you're talking about the year
without a summer today says zach
since there was a pretty big eruption
from a japanese volcano a few hours ago
actually wow that's like a total kerwins
coincidence yeah a coincidence that's
what that is yeah uh but yeah we're
gonna talk about that year without a
summer all that kind of stuff uh which
was a rasputina song too wasn't it i
think so yeah 1816 the year that summer
and it was about this and that um
you know obviously even though a really
bunch of bad [ __ ] happened it was like a
global
disaster essentially um
but
i just think you're i think it's funny
how we they do seem to be very modern
but i think that's only just because
we were raised by boomer parents who
were coming out of the 50s and the 60s
and that particular time was [ __ ]
stuffy
really it's just kind of returning to
normal
yeah because you could almost say like i
said uh you know mary shelley in that
circle
um you know the people she hung out with
and her parents too even
uh were actually very radical for the
time but you know very into like
political reform you know they were
anti-authoritarian anti-uh theology they
just were really they were atheists um
which was
like i said they were respected within
kind of intellectual circles but society
at large kind of looked down on them a
little bit
well the working class and the people
have always liked religions
you know and
speak out against religion too much and
they'll [ __ ] come down on you that's
not as bad as it was
but it's cyclical
yeah cyclical yeah
and they just ha
they were all they were living in the
times that was
the early 1800s late 1700s
like i said
it was this time of sexual revolution it
was probably kind of
closer to the 60s really yeah and uh
several people have made that comparison
and like i said it's not it wasn't i
don't think it was all that widespread
or at least it wasn't um
seen as wise like if you were doing it
like everyone would kind of be like yeah
you know what i mean but well there was
no mass media yeah so uh cultural
movements didn't usually
spread far and wide or maybe only
through three or four cities across a
couple different countries
and then maybe like certain segments of
those cities the people who and then the
people that were writing about it that's
how people would know wasn't mainstream
yeah that's that's a good way of putting
it that's kind of what i was gonna
that's why i was saying like it was sort
of like a certain segment of elite
circles
uh intellectuals uh it was kind of
widespread there but in
society as a whole it was still kind of
like frowned upon this is pre-industrial
revolution the main mains the mainstream
were tilling soil and raising [ __ ]
cows and working on farms they had no
time to
get involved in any damn underground
scenes reading books and writing and
swapping and [ __ ] they
didn't have time for that breaking and
swapping yeah here you [ __ ] my wife i'm
gonna take yours there probably was some
swapping going on but yeah they probably
kept it on it was that barnyard
swashbuck
it was that barnyard he's cheating on
one cow with the other cow well no just
saying that they're all in the barnyard
drinking [ __ ] moonshine well that was
i think it's pre just a free
distillation drinking and [ __ ] one
thing happens and another thing happens
and next you know it's just a bunch of
farm people [ __ ]
that's been going on fire [ __ ] fresh
[ __ ] yeah yeah
like
wild sex in the working class from boy
go boy
it's like that song please tell me that
there's kind of like a redneck porn
called farm fresh [ __ ] i don't know
gotta be i mean there gotta be a whole
well there's like a cowgirl fetish and
[ __ ] like that and there's some yeah
they've got [ __ ] like well like i said
anything you could imagine there's porn
of it yeah that's rule 34 right gay
cowboy fetish and [ __ ] they got that
yeah that's been around forever farm
fresh [ __ ] now i want to see that
movie actually no i don't but i just
like that title
sid vicious went to [ __ ] texas and
did a live show with two [ __ ]
illustrations of gay cowboys on his
t-shirt in texas yeah
to gay cowboys they did they tried to
beat his ass yeah the texans didn't cop
not like that
but he did it on purpose like i said the
whole the whole point of punk was like
provocation
yeah you're supposed to like make people
mad they were the original trolls yeah
well not the original trolls they've
been trolling
since time immemorial but yeah they
that's kind of the whole that was their
whole thing
uh but yeah so time of the american
revolution and [ __ ] in the [ __ ] when
they were fighting the british empire
was like out of somehow star wars but
that was like the 1960s
go back and read american revolutionary
history of what was going on in the
[ __ ] maine towns on in those colonies
when they were fighting it sounds like
it's happening today trolling leaders in
public [ __ ] beating people up tired
feathering people going to their houses
and protesting and burning the house
down [ __ ] um everybody calling
everybody else a traitor if you were
not a loyalist you were a traitor if you
were a loyalist you were a traitor it
was and then there was
sex going on
uh in in the new england colonies a lot
of it was like you know out of wedlock
interracial
stuff [ __ ] with these indian girls
black girls black guys with white women
it's all recorded it's all there
matter of fact the first dude killed in
the american revolution was a was a
a mixed guy who got
he basically got hit by kind of by like
by a stray round that the british fired
off i think it was supposed to be a
warning shot it hit him and killed him
and that's really what started the um i
forgot what his name was that was a hell
of a warning wasn't it yeah well the
british troops were pretty rattled and i
think some of them ended up later on
british troops were being accused of
murder
but then you had american revolutionary
guys who were honorable enough to defend
them in court and get some of them off
because it wasn't on them they were
being ordered to do things yeah you know
um
now they did time in jail but they
didn't hang them
you know
[ __ ]
but you know interesting time but if you
read what was going on there
you can say that well damn that's like
the 60s or that's like right now
it can it can fit
yeah so and
you can also say that for certain
aspects of roman history
mankind is pretty much
the same
really over time in the west
the east not so much but
but the east is still the east like
china and japan and korea's you know
what i mean they've changed a bit but
not totally well it's the same with dust
you know what i mean yeah everything's
just cycles cycles of the same kind of
revolutions and then yeah
so everything just kind of yeah so it's
kind of like why
i don't get overly upset about things
because it's all pretty much been done
it's all been done before everything's
been done before and then you know and
the fact that we're talking about the
american revolution that's actually kind
of uh germaine to this topic too because
the background that mary shelley grew up
in
uh was very much based in enlightenment
reform um you know and all this idea of
like radical trying to get rid of the
monarchy trying to get rid of uh you
know the church out of political life
yeah separation of church and state you
know that was what yeah that was very
much in the zeitgeist at that time so it
all kind of like went together it was a
very revolutionary time period well i
mean you know the french revolution all
that kind of stuff was going on now some
people go well wait a minute the united
states was a christian country and this
and that you have to kind of read
between the lines
um thomas jefferson who had a lot to do
with the constitution had his version of
the bible where he cut a lot of the
[ __ ] out of the new testament he cut
a lot of the [ __ ] out and left in
what he thought was supposed to what it
really took out like all the
supernatural yeah pretty much he tried
to make so
it was a secular society it was not a
jesus-based
society because at all because you'd had
constant fighting
because in that in that time the the
christian sects were at constant war
with each other between catholics and
protestants and then different kinds of
lutherans and weird things that they had
quakers and
um you know
america was
was a lot different than europe america
was a collection of christian cults most
of them not really getting along with
each other you didn't want them to have
true power they had that and that's why
you ended up with the salem witch trials
yeah that's that's not that's not what
anyone wants
[Laughter]
they were saying basically it says you
got a
a a moral people and religion
religiosity can provide a certain amount
of moralism a moral people's what you
need for a republic because it's about
being fair and balancing everything out
uh but then you have a
a constitution and the supreme court to
decide things and
and you want to try to keep religion out
of it as much as possible and in a way
they were also saying you have to try to
keep politics out of it um it was
supposed to be just a bunch of you'd be
like we mean politics well they almost
wanted to ban political parties
but they said well
probably nothing you could do
even if there was no political parties
political gangs would form they would
just be political parties just didn't
wouldn't have names
yeah so
we ended up with what we have it was an
experiment and it slowly became an
empire
i think it'll go back to the way it was
though
the empires are if you look at history
they're not sustainable
because they're they're too diverse
you just can't have something that big
too many people
can't get that many people to agree
that's true so
they're coming out of a time that very
similar to what's going on now that's
what that's what why we're talking about
it the revolutionary american
revolutionary period yeah kind of like
now kind of like the 60s
yeah and you know like i said it's very
cyclical stop prop says it was a great
tv movie called frankenstein the true
story and it was pretty close to mary
shelley's story maybe from the 80s i
think i remember what you're talking
about actually
um and then camp guy said i remember a
tv mini series where the monster ended
up on an icebound ship well isn't that
the way the novel ends though like he
goes up to the arctic or whatever i
haven't read it since and then
frankenstein like dr frankenstein like
follows monster up there i remember
reading it back in high school and was
kind of disappointed with it because it
just was so long
this book is so long it wasn't like it
wasn't like the movie
yeah the movie is really not
hardly anything like the book well the
book is very like philosophical but like
i said that's because mary shelley's
parents were both philosophers
and she had grown up um being around
like intellectuals writers other
philosophers i mean the household
at the time she had just grown up
surrounded by these ideas so that was
something that was very much like in the
culture at the time or the culture that
she grew up in
um and it's interesting too that
this always blew my mind that mary
shelley
wrote frankenstein when she was
19
years old
which is crazy she had written i mean
she like wrote little stories and stuff
when she was a kid but she'd never
really written anything
you know super serious or anything like
that and she really didn't feel like all
that adequate about it but the fact that
she was at this gathering with two other
big literary giants of the time and hers
is the really the only thing that
endured this long and think about the
cultural impact that frankenstein has
had written by a 19 year old girl who
had never really written anything before
um
is just like crazy to me
and i think too that i don't know her
upbringing to me seemed to inform a lot
particularly frankenstein i mean she
wrote [ __ ] loads of stuff like later on
which i kind of want to get into that at
the end because
um i don't really think that up until
quite recently
uh no one really gave that much of a
[ __ ] about any of the other [ __ ] that
she wrote after because frankenstein but
she actually wrote a [ __ ] ton of like
novels and plays and all this other kind
of stuff and they're actually and i and
i guess like in the last decade or so
they've been getting like a critical
reappraisal and people like oh my god
like why
you know why is frankenstein the only
thing that's like known from her because
she did write like a [ __ ] ton of other
stuff later her writing that at 19
doesn't surprise me at all because when
you look at a lot of some of the
greatest arts produced by really young
people
some of the best heavy metal around that
around 18 that's true i guess some of
the [ __ ] some of the best operas and
[ __ ] for freaking you know i'm a [ __ ]
wolf gang
mozart i wanna dance mozart writing
stuff around that age it's just [ __ ]
mind-blowing although he was kind of
like a child prodigy yeah i mean but
kids from this class in that time were
children prodigies a lot of them because
they were
they were tutored at home by expensive
tutors and usually from an early age
and they were married a lot of times by
the time they were 14 or 15 19 wasn't
that
young in the in the 1800s 1700s
and mary shelley i mean she got because
of her parents beliefs
she actually got um she didn't have a
lot of formal education but she did have
a lot i mean her father in particular
was very was adamant that because i mean
at this point
this was still a time period where women
they considered like education they
really didn't consider education all
that important for women because they
were just going to get married off and
be wives so
the fact that she was um that she had
all these tutors that she was around all
these intellectuals at the time and her
father
uh considered her at an equal with men
which was unusual at the time um i think
that also like really informed her uh
later writing as well education back
then didn't didn't really mean anything
anyway i mean one man could learn could
go to a university in in his lifetime in
a short period of time really maybe
eight years ten years could basically
learn the sum of all human knowledge
because there wasn't much there wasn't
much there so post-it note okay
and a lot of what they were learning
wasn't that practical
you couldn't do anything with it
in penmanship
there was some stuff that you know they
had you know [ __ ]
the very basics of [ __ ] you know
mathematics and [ __ ] you know
calculus and triggering they knew all
but what could you do with that back
then
there wasn't even a
the industrial revolution hadn't started
so you couldn't really apply it too much
and i mean unless you were going into
the sciences and even the sciences were
very rudimentary at that point like to
say the least yeah there science science
was about figuring [ __ ] out
just
my laboratory
i'm gonna start shocking these animals
yeah that happens and that yeah and
that's what they were doing that
actually plays a lot into uh mary
shelley's upbringing not her particular
upbringing but you know why she got the
idea what would happen if i took the
blood out of a cat and put a dog's blood
in it yeah they did [ __ ] like that
i'm gonna say this the cat died i wonder
why
[Laughter]
well like i said this was kind of during
the enlightenment era where they were
just kind of like you know let's do all
these experiments and figure that out
which to us that seems it's like duh but
that was kind of like a big deal we knew
about the scientific method you had to
prove things and yeah and you had to you
know and you had to do experiments over
and over with different factors changed
like to figure out what was going to
happen what happens if i do this what
happens
why did that happen yeah
which you know i think people had been i
mean people have been doing that without
really realizing it
for thousands of years but i mean i kind
of feel like during the light most of
the time and all that was kind of like
codified into an actual method that
everybody was you know a step a step b
steps
in the 1700s at least i'm assuming the
18s is the same way because it was
pre-industrial revolution in the 1700s
the sciences
that was a rich man's sport it was just
a hobby
every scientist was a rich dude that
could afford to buy [ __ ] and could
afford to like do experiments well they
could afford the leisure time it was all
leisure to set up their own laboratory
and like and they lost money they didn't
make money there was no industries to
sell any of that [ __ ] to
um
now there were some exceptions you know
if you were close to the king and you
were a good mechanical engineer you
might be to come up with a new set of
sights for a [ __ ] cannon and maybe
show and demonstrate that oh yeah we can
uh now use mechanical sights on a cannon
but half the time when you saw what they
were buying it was like [ __ ] up
it still didn't work
you know kind of more like a con job
like well why didn't we put a gear here
why didn't this why isn't it ratchet on
both sides why can't you do this it was
always kind of like half ass
might be pretty though it's like the
same [ __ ] they sell on infomercials yeah
it might be pretty pretty though highly
decorated but it just doesn't didn't
really deliver as promised
because it was just the concept of one
dude who was rich who kind of thought
about it
yeah i kind of thought yeah
maybe this will work yeah that's cool
yeah
hugo says i think mary shelley's parents
were also writers yes they were they're
both uh philosophers and writers as well
which we'll get into in a moment before
we do that i think i've shown this on
the show before
but this is how much i
just love this
historical incident this story or
whatever i did a board game it's a card
game board game sort of thing uh like i
said i think i've shown this before but
see this is it here i made this a while
back like last year or something like
that
and uh basically what you do is you play
as one of the characters you can play as
mary shelley percy shelley lord byron
claire claremont and john polidori or
john polidori and basically you're
trying to get these cards and kind of
like complete
the works that they wrote during this
particular
summer
which like i said
although frankenstein is the best
remembered there were some other things
that happened during that thing that
maybe led to some other [ __ ] later on so
you know i kind of find that really fast
mike says there will always be a
separation between science and religions
and i will tell you you are absolutely
wrong absolutely
no throughout the past most science was
based in religion that's why it [ __ ]
didn't work
well i think that's what he meant okay i
think that's what he meant yeah but then
there's a lot of [ __ ] because it's two
opposite ways of looking at the world
really yeah but there's i can show you
[ __ ] things that are supposedly
science and you [ __ ] when you think
about it no it's religion
yeah no like for instance on the ar-15
the forward bolt assist what the [ __ ] is
that doing there well just to make you
feel better
it doesn't make that [ __ ] rifle
fire any better or any reliable matter
of fact it's a [ __ ]
it's a mistake if you try to chamber a
[ __ ] round in there and you start
beating on a forward assault forward
assist you're gonna make that
[ __ ] malfunction you're not
gonna [ __ ] remedy a malfunction so no
there's there's lots of [ __ ]
superstitions and
backwards thinking and [ __ ] religion
involved in [ __ ]
even weapons even weapons of sciences
but it's there because
it had to be there to make the army feel
better about buying it
but see at that point like i said at
that point when you're saying that well
that's not science anymore because
there's not a scientist i know he's
infrared yeah but the thing is is that
you can go through most of the things
that are out there in existence that
governments are buying it and there's
always some kind of [ __ ] hokiness
in that thing and it had to be hokey in
order for them to buy it because the
leaders that are running those systems
are [ __ ] up
they're going by emotion
not by what's real and that's just a
that's a [ __ ] universal constant
you know
well that's kind of how most people
operate but like i said that's why i
think it's important to learn
scientific method critical thinking
stuff like that so you know how to like
short-circuit that kind of scenario yeah
the problem is is that that method falls
into the hands of people with 80 or 90
iqs and they just can't apply that
they're dumb
what was that i don't know i heard some
kids screaming
scared the crap out of me right so the
higher your iq the the
the the better the easier it will be for
you to follow a scientific method but
when that happens you'll piss a lot of
people off because you'll be very
dispassionate and you'll start saying
things like you know what why do we have
old people they don't make enough money
they're not really here for anything you
just do all kinds of weird [ __ ] why do
ugly people exist
you know
and then you say well that's crazy no
there were a lot of [ __ ] the both the
soviets and the nazis were like that
trying to develop the [ __ ]
uh with soviet superman and things like
that you look like a damn statues you
know eugenics and selective breeding no
they all they tried all that [ __ ]
now
is that science
no not really
it's a religion
well because they had a well yeah
because they had a preconcept
in mind right right and they were just
kind of like so like i said that's why
science and religion just using those
two terms very loosely are looking at
the world in two different ways uh
religion you have an established thing
at that like you know for example god
exists and so you're just kind of like
sort of formulating everything to get to
that okay i see where you're coming from
now yeah yeah we're just disagreeing
over what a religion is because i'm also
taking an account for all the
philosophies that even don't even
believe in religion like
buddhism buddhism is a religion but it
doesn't have a concept of well i'm
talking about when i say religion i said
that's a very loose term i'm just
talking about any kind of like magical
thinking any sort of magical thinking
which can be applied to anything yeah
well that's superstition anything we
start opening that up that's 90 percent
of human history and everything that
well yeah right now just it's just
[ __ ] up well that's why i'm saying
that you know scientology the scientific
method
you know even though people had been
doing it
without really realizing it like for
example the first thing i think of
animal husbandry yeah um you know they
they had figured out evolution natural
selection before that was ever
codified like before anybody before
darwin had come up with a mechanism you
know they figured it out because they're
like oh well if you breed these two
together then it'll have a baby that has
these characteristics so they were doing
that beforehand even though they didn't
know what the mechanism for it was so
people do have
a sort of natural proclivity
to that if the at least if they're
observing
nature or whatever it is that happens
you know they they do understand cause
and effect
in a certain fashion but
uh we also have things in our brains
that can circumvent that
uh by giving you like essentially false
positives it's like oh well you know
this happened after that happened
therefore the first thing must have
caused the second thing which is not
always the case right and you know and
of course we're human beings we have
limited intellect even a genius is like
170 iq from the point of view of like a
a [ __ ] extraterrestrial that is
millions and millions of years ahead of
us in evolution they would just see us
as a chimpanzee or a squirrel you know
an unintelligent creature
so you're only going to be able to just
do so well
you know like you have these
human geniuses trying to engineer things
well we're going to make a utopian
society an alien would come and look and
just see us as a [ __ ] bunch of fruit
flies in a jar and they would go oh you
can't do anything with that they would
just kill us
the dumbasses are just going to hold us
back yeah yeah they're always holding
this start over you know it'd be like
that
so and then they blow up the earth
just sterilize it and then [ __ ]
hopefully the [ __ ] nature would
reboot and something better would come
about
we have a certain amount of [ __ ] what
do you call it damn um
oh
we think a lot of ourselves and but it's
just because we're humans and we're
looking seeing things from our point of
views all creatures do that no matter
how primitive they are i would think
solipsism
you know yeah i mean it's kind of hard
not to be like that yeah it's you really
have to make a conscious effort right it
will sound true science is like that
true science would be like yes you're a
human
yeah whatever you know yeah like machine
intelligence is better go ahead and make
really intelligent machines and you guys
all need to kill yourself to make room
for true intelligence and would people
do that today [ __ ] no they wouldn't do
that they wouldn't do that
yeah yeah
danny rolling ghostface says mary
shelley's frankenstein was the first
book i ever read start to finish and the
cover art is what got me to want to read
the book you're just saying yeah it's
kind of like one of those books because
it's crazy that like frankenstein is so
[ __ ] like the the story is so
ubiquitous around the world really
um that i kind of feel like most people
have seen some movie or tv iteration of
it and then when they read the book like
in high school or or wherever i can't
remember if i read it in junior high or
high school
when it was assigned but um they're
always kind of like disappointed because
it's just kind of like well it's nothing
like
the movies which it's not
but i mean the story is kind of the same
but you know it's it's one of those
things i kind of feel like people have
the same thing with dracula a little bit
because
the dracula you know the movie that they
made of dracula like under like the
bellagosi one and stuff like that were
actually based on the stage play which
was a very simplified version of the
novel so the novel is really not that
much of anything like the movies i mean
it's essentially the same story but
there's a lot of other [ __ ] serpent
surfer says he hopes that
extraterrestrials are out there or those
coke snorting aliens ought to have the
movie heavy metal
what they call that zork
was it a sword or something
like that yeah it came in a damn [ __ ]
like a lawn mower that would dispense it
and they'd sit there like it snorted off
the ship's deck they had the hottie that
they picked up the robot got like
lawnmower yeah the robot got lit hey i
remember that one yes we just watched
that night metal is the [ __ ] man
[ __ ] funny oh my god the robot gets
the redhead yeah and the robot looked
like a mouse
that's right
yeah i kind of we're gonna have to
re-watch that probably we just watched
it not too long ago but i can't remember
that much about it
the loch ner yeah they need to remake
that [ __ ] and make it even less pc it
should make it just makes everybody
[ __ ] mad that's the way [ __ ]
reading heavy metal magazine was like
bdsm you were it was gonna put you
through some [ __ ] especially when you
were a kid that's looking funny man i
like that [ __ ]
thank you zach
the gary oldman dracula is one of my
all-time favorites and i wish there was
a version of frankenstein that was on
that level of quality to me yeah i kind
of feel like i don't know like i feel
like the de niro wanna yeah well i was
gonna say the kenneth branagh one yeah
um that one was i don't know i kind of
feel like i saw that in the theater
and i remember kind of liking it at the
time but it was just kind of like i was
like this is either like really awesome
or really terrible and i can't really
decide um you know what i mean so it's
one of those kind of things i do kind of
feel like
yeah i don't know i haven't seen as many
i don't think i've seen as many
adaptations of frankenstein i mean i
know there are probably
equally as many as there are dracula but
i haven't seen as many of them
um obviously like the first uh you know
the james whale one you know
frankenstein and bride of frankenstein
um are still my go-to because you know
how can you beat that you can't but i do
kind of feel like it's long past overdue
for somebody somewhere to do maybe a
series that is actually like faithful to
the book you know what i'm saying
because i feel like i don't know i feel
like the one with the robert de niro
like i said it was fairly faithful to
the book because i do kind of feel like
a lot of the movies leave out the whole
arctic situation and all that kind of
stuff and i do remember that movie
having that and i think that that was
the first time i'd actually i was like
oh wow they actually did this in the
movie where they don't usually
but
i don't know serpent surfer comes
because no it was called plutonium
nyborg nosedive
yeah
nyborg yeah
yeah yeah um but yeah i want to say too
like uh there have also been a couple of
movies actually i think there are three
movies that i know of
uh that were adaptate well not an
adaptation but were actually uh
fictionalizations of
this particular incident we're talking
about like the summer of 1816 like the
origin of frankenstein uh one of those
was called gothic uh it was directed by
ken russell uh and that came out in 1986
that's actually my favorite one there
was also one called haunted summer which
came out i think that came out in 1988
that one's pretty good too it's a little
over ripe uh i kind of want to say
julian sands was in it but i might be
wrong about that
and i think though so i've seen both of
those and those are both worth watching
and then there was a spanish language
one and i can't remember the title of it
but i haven't seen that one yet but i
just those are the three that i know if
there might be more
um but so
you know so so this so this incident has
also been moving
uh on top of like
and then there was the whole i was going
to say too there was the whole uh movie
that came out a few years ago gods and
monsters but that was more about james
whale like as a person
and him making frankenstein
that's also an excellent movie by the
way
[Music]
so yeah
what are we gonna say nothing oh okay i
thought you're gonna say something no
just looking at her yeah megan was just
talking about the kenneth branagh
version yeah it's like i i need to
rewatch it because like i said i i saw
in the theater
and i think i think that might have been
the only time i saw it and i remember
liking it because i was like oh this is
like pretty close to the book like he
seemed to
go out of his way to make it like book
accurate but then i thought it was like
maybe a little bit over the top but i
don't know i'd have to see it again
because it's been such a long time
also you guys do you remember that movie
from 1985 the bride that had sting and
jennifer wheels in it yeah i remember i
remember seeing the trailer when it came
out it looked cool but i never did see
it i was like super into that movie this
time even though it doesn't really
have much of anything to do i mean it
has something to do with the book
obviously because sting plays victor
frankenstein but
it's kind of like
i don't know it's like a just a really
weird like we took a lot of poetic
license with this story anything about
sting is that he could act yeah he just
didn't make very many movies yeah
yeah he was i actually really liked him
in the bride yeah um he plays a good
villain he was good like i said we did
brimstone and treacle he's insufferable
man that motherfucker's an insufferable
[ __ ] [ __ ] well everybody knows that i
mean not as insufferable as bono yeah
yeah oh no yeah yeah yeah bono's much
worse i mean bono is kind of like the
gold standard of insufferable yeah
[Laughter]
sting is the kind of [ __ ] that
would just back off the camera and sit
in a lotus position and start [ __ ]
playing little [ __ ] guitars and [ __ ]
trying to get your woman's [ __ ] pants
using [ __ ] some kind of some kind of
kamasutra [ __ ] tantras and [ __ ] like
that he's gonna do with [ __ ] indian
religions or something yeah he's like on
he's like on tv talking about like him
and his wife's like tantric five-hour
sex session try to get your woman to
crawl up into his lap
and ride on his yawni
his
i couldn't believe that [ __ ] man i saw
this i saw a show on that one time an
old man [ __ ] his [ __ ] was dragging on
the ground he had it tied around his
waist it looked fake i was like
ah he really did that man
hey [ __ ] couldn't
there's no way you could get that [ __ ]
inflated
yeah what would that even i don't know i
don't think it worked man now i'm like
thinking about that about three feet
long grody yeah
what did he want he's overcompensating
did he want to be able to suck his own
dick
it had that had to be the [ __ ] hidden
motive i think but it's see that's what
that that's the first thing i would
think of it's like why do you really
need one that long because that's not
going to help that's not going to help a
sister maybe it was fake maybe it was
something that they put on there that
kind of [ __ ] looks like a [ __ ] big
old flaccid dick and then they they're
because they work on the streets are
like those [ __ ] years yeah you know and
they're
they're fake holy men yeah
it's like look i'm floating
do you want the flu
yeah i remember that youtube video i
wish loved it i wish i could find that
again i don't know it might have been
some kind of where it was attached in a
[ __ ]
might have been attached to something
you know not other than his dick but
he's pulling it out i was going that
looks real
and uh he's stretching it like that
he's jumping right yeah
and
you know jump rope with your dick you
know need to say some [ __ ] he'll say
some [ __ ] like you know
you must
have expended the lingam
the energy
energy of the universe
energy of creation the size of my lingam
you know whatever okay so
you got a big dick which means that you
tapped into the force the force that
created the universe obi-wan kenobi
would really like to [ __ ] find out
more about that [ __ ] you know so he
really thinks he's tapped into the uh
like secret hidden secrets of the
universe
because he made his dick longer yeah
that sounds about right making you dick
longer because your dick is at the
center of the universe gives you a
greater affinity to the force basically
what you say
it's like a lightning rod yeah like
you kind of hold it up and it kind of
wilts then you walk around a crowd of
people in india and they're amazed and
they give you money
and i guess dudes give you money in
hopes that their dicks will get big
it's nice that's this whole racket they
have worked out it's a racket thing you
know i mean it's like they don't have
their vacuum pumps down there in india
they can't afford to buy it it's just
wishful thinking they give it they give
one big dig big dick [ __ ] some
money and you sit back and wait for it
to happen yeah waiting for that
spiritual energy to flow through it
[Laughter]
turn your dick into a garden hose but
you know it's been so long since i've
seen that
you could totally be pulling out of your
ass no no well not totally what
if i were to see it again maybe it
wouldn't fool me if it was fake
yeah because i wasn't really wasn't
looking for any kind of sleight of hand
tricks
i wasn't 100
certain that that was a dick
you know man yeah
it might have been something else well
you're not used to seeing anyone like
that she's like three or four feet long
and he's like that shape
doing like this and pulling that [ __ ]
out like the hose and [ __ ]
yeah you guys can look at these lasso
when people
talking to people with it in his hand
and [ __ ] like dude wash your hands man
you're trying to shake hands with people
i don't know how to wash your hands bro
but you guys can go back and look at
that i think that i think i actually saw
that on youtube
because of course you did yeah i think
it was on youtube but it was like off of
something from television that they had
yeah
they just lifted themselves dirty as
[ __ ] dick would get you'd have to
like roll it up and like tie it around
and [ __ ] like that and you'd have to put
like a twist tie around it yeah and he
wasn't by himself he was with like four
other dudes that had their own
specialties you know it's kind of like a
traveling circus
on the street like some dudes are
actually you know charming cobras and
[ __ ] and
he's like charlie cobra
he's
[Laughter]
front rows will get wet they give you
like plastic [ __ ] slickers and stuff
to like put on like they do at seaworld
proper gas is i think he wraps it around
a stick i think that's right that sounds
realistic yeah yeah yeah
you saw it too i've seen i think there's
more than one dude that does that
everything i think that's that's just
kind of like that indian rope trick
thing it's like that's kind of one of
their
arsenal of like little magic tricks or
whatever it might have been a magic
trick
i'm sure it probably was i don't think
that
i mean you know
you can stretch your skin out to a
certain extent
because you know people do it with their
ears like with gauges and stuff like
that if you do it slowly but they got
those japanese guys that go to those
dick festivals and they hang like a 50
the ch the chinese do it too i think it
was the chinese that
they both do have the dick festivals but
the chinese were doing things like
tying 50 pound weights and swinging it
like that and they're wearing their
[ __ ] kung fu outfits and it's
supposed to be like approved for [ __ ]
your strength and i don't see i'm not
seeing even my dick can lift 50 yeah
yeah i'm not really seeing any strength
there you know what i mean [ __ ] and
i'm like [ __ ] dude man
pull that [ __ ] off let's see how let's
let's see that thing yeah because
there's no proof that there's a weight
tied to your dick
yeah it could just be styrofoam yeah it
could might be just tied around there
dude at the jim rose circus sideshow
that had that mr lifto mr liftow he
didn't just do his dick i think he
pulled he had like cement blocks hanging
from his nipples and his dick and stuff
yeah so yeah so ask me those are all
it's a car it's a car anything if you
ask me those dudes were all just trying
to cash in on failed dick expansion
experiments
if i tie a 20 pound dip weight to the
end of my dick i might have a foot long
dick after a year or so
and hey subway here's my foot
long back he only got like three extra
inches on it so his four inch ass is
[ __ ] walking around that [ __ ] he's
like man that's it i can't i gotta
figure out how to make money off this
yeah you know i was gonna sell this [ __ ]
to the women but they're not buying
four inches wasn't enough
so you know it's just
it's got to be something like that i'm
just trying to put i'm trying to use i'm
trying to man explain to myself how a
[ __ ] stumbles into tying a
20-pound dick to your pound weight to
you dude yeah i'd be interested to know
like the uh the spiritual power the
series of happenstances that led to that
outcome i'm buying in this religious
explanation of spiritual power i don't
think that's what it was i think there
was no i think there was viagra slash
dick expansion yeah that was that's
spiritual [ __ ] that was that was like
some justification after that in fact
yeah like that's how that was it was
i was trying to have a greater
connection to the [ __ ] to the yin the
yang force of the universe you know
the dick at the center
of the center universe created
everything
it's right in the middle of that galaxy
it's all spinning around one big old day
yeah it's a [ __ ] inside a dick and it
just spins spins it makes a bunch of
noises and what squirts out of it is
[ __ ] the universe of course like what
always happens
don't think that somebody didn't come up
with that [ __ ] because you know that
they did it
back and forth dude [ __ ] brought it
all down the world it's about [ __ ]
yeah the universe is about [ __ ]
it's like yeah my jizz spray just like
that created the whole verse
there it is
matt cool story man that's good
how does this always happen how does
this always happen we're doing a show
about mary shelley and all of a sudden
we're talking about this is this show
and i'm [ __ ] on it
and then suddenly we're talking about a
dick
and jizz creating the universe yeah yeah
how does this happen i don't even know
now i have to go back through all the
steps like this yeah i don't know oh my
god i don't know oh my god so we're
already like an hour in i mean we did
kind of talk about frankenstein yeah
yeah we're getting something we're
talking about we're just we're going off
on tangents like i said yeah
tangents that's why everybody watches
the show
is because we don't even we don't even
know how this [ __ ] happens i certainly
don't know how it happens um but you
know because i'm gonna let it ride
you're gonna yeah it's it's okay i'm
just gonna let jenny handler hurt the
business
well you guys you know this you know
about this you know about this story
yeah uh so you can uh i'll chip in with
you you can like chip this appropriate
so let's kind of talk about mary shelley
a little bit because i do kind of feel
like her background her upbringing stuff
like that did actually like i mentioned
earlier kind of like inform her later
writing of frankenstein and led to a lot
of um
the things that happened in her life
that maybe because this poor girl i mean
she uh she had some like bad [ __ ] happen
to her man like she there was a lot of
like deaths
she pretty much survived
every single person in her entire life
that was that she loved that was kind of
common though in that era it was i guess
but i mean even by those even by that
metric uh she did actually like uh
endure a lot of tragedy in her life
in regards to like people close to her
dying there's a lot of stories of dudes
in the 1800s you know trying to make a
living in a town or a city and then you
follow their family life and you find it
god damn everybody he knows is now dead
his wife's dead his [ __ ] kids died
and then they kept on going they just
remarry and get another one and
let me see that some of them broke down
though they couldn't take it and then
they died you know some
i mean that's what happened back in the
day when one they didn't really know
that germs caused disease so surgeons be
like reaching their dirty ass hands
inside of your body no antibiotics that
had no antibiotics um nobody tv got them
yeah nobody really understood that like
you shouldn't drink water that has like
[ __ ] molecules in it um you know nobody
knew you really weren't supposed to be
constantly drinking alcohol all day all
day long although i will say that it
saved them those yeah that's what i was
going to say in a lot of situations
particularly and i was reading about
this like in uh britain like before they
figured out like you know before the
they figured out that like you know
[ __ ] water was like not good drink that
they would kill you um probably people
that just drank beer for every meal and
didn't drink any water yeah uh were
probably much healthier than people that
drank the water because the water was
like full of microorganisms
also i don't i don't give a [ __ ] what
they say they were eating when you see
did you see photographs of people from
the 1800s even late 1800s you know
that's when there was photography
i can just tell by those builds they are
extremely low protein diet
extremely low
well it was hard to get hold of i mean
you know
well that leads you that leaves you open
to a lot of things little bitty narrow
shoulders which means when during their
formative years they weren't eating well
they just eat crap bread probably
yeah yeah bread and you have to think
too that even like um
photography when it was a new uh
phenomenon
uh it was very expensive so the
photographs that you're seeing from
early days of photography were generally
like upper middle class to upper class
people because lower class people cannot
afford to get photographed generally so
even then you're seeing like good
wealthy people yeah of the time so you
can imagine that people that lived in
poverty looked like a million times
worse yeah well they probably looked 30
years older than they really were oh i'm
sure and probably pretty small
i mean because they're
people that could afford photography a
lot of the guys when you look at their
head to shoulder ratio
little bitty upper body a little upper
rib cages i mean rip rib cage is like a
[ __ ] 12 year old boy which that's
that's a sure sign of malnutrition what
are you doing
what are you doing i've never seen that
no she that's what i was telling you get
down
see i'm afraid that that picture is
gonna fall on her head
so it's like i might have to take it
down she thinks there's something behind
that well that's what i was telling you
i know what it is yeah see the cat's
tail yeah in the drawing she thinks
that's a lizard oh maybe she thinks it's
a lizard tail yeah she keeps going up
there scratching like trying to well
she's trying to get through the mirror
too right but get behind her you got to
watch her because like i said i'm kind
of afraid that she's going to knock her
off she uh what i was going to say is
i've seen photographs those dudes and
that's definite signs of malnutrition
and that what that does is during your
formative years it affects iq it also
just affects health in general
you know if they get sick they don't
have the strength to fight it off you
know
yeah people like drop them like flies
right
i mean people like [ __ ] that people
wouldn't even really notice nowadays
like an illness that people wouldn't
really notice or it would just be like
oh you know a couple days and you're
fine you killed him back it would kill
him back then which like i said you know
life was uh kind of
not even even for people with money it
really wasn't uh all that fantastic and
like i said most of the you know a lot
of the babies died very young yeah which
is another thing that happened a lot to
mary shelley so yeah
a lot of it was knowledge
yeah they known they could have avoided
avoided a lot of that [ __ ] they didn't
even know yeah like i said so so much
[ __ ] uh was alleviated just because of
simple like hand washing yeah and that
was something that really didn't occur
to people like cleanliness in general
like hey let's not have an open sewer
you know through the streets of the city
which ah duh but that seems like common
sense but it wasn't for like how bad it
was i want people to kind of put wrap
your mind around the palace of
versailles which is [ __ ] one of the
biggest [ __ ] most opulent palaces
ever over in [ __ ] france right
he had some of the [ __ ] great kings
and royalties it's still there it's
beautiful they forgot to put [ __ ]
bathrooms in it
yeah because the king don't [ __ ]
there's no bathrooms in it so they have
huge parties guess what they just pissed
in the [ __ ] stairwells they said it
was [ __ ] nasty
after those parties they'd be just
pooping in pots and like throw it out of
the way and the [ __ ] stairwells they
and it was kind of the pals was more
kind and this is in the [ __ ]
huge [ __ ] palace pissing behind the
draperies nobles noblemen's noble and
[ __ ] royalty we're doing here i'm
just i'm being sneaky just thinking
behind going behind taking a piss okay
and then they had dogs running around
and dogs are pissed too he said you
couldn't go every time you go up and
down the stairs it was like going
through a waterfall of [ __ ] piss
and they
it's almost kind of like they didn't
know any better which like i said it's
crazy crazy when you think about it it
is
um you know and
i think i mentioned on uh the last show
that i'm rereading uh drew to the novel
by dan simmons which if you didn't know
was set in the 1860s uh in london
because it's about charles dickens and
wilkie collins and stuff
and um
he goes a lot into
what the london of the 1860s was like
and it was basically the same thing
these you know charles dickens and
wilkie collins you know in real life
were
gentlemen they were like upper class uh
but they still you walked through the
streets and the streets were just like
cesspits yeah of [ __ ] i mean like uh
every everything got dumped into the
thames into the river yeah um and there
was one point i think it was 1865 i want
to say or something like that this one
year it was called the great stink
where
uh the river smelled so bad that people
like if you could afford to leave what
are you doing stop please stop tearing
[ __ ] up please stop she wants attention
yeah that uh the smell was so bad that
like if you could afford to leave the
city everybody had to leave they had to
go like out of the country because
people were just like
the smell was just overpowering of just
like poop
and dead bodies in the river because
everybody just thought well we'll just
put it in the river like the water will
make it go away i guess but it just
stays there there was no track waste
disposal in most of these cities
no central life and when they did maybe
it was just so simple teams of guys and
carts
um
yeah it's like you'd go and they'd have
like uh people that were basically
freelancers that would kind of go and
sweep stuff up and look through this
stuff for valuable things some of these
cities had huge problems because it was
horse powered and the horses would just
[ __ ] [ __ ] on the road and just get
piled up on the sides all the roads
and of the downtown areas people had to
walk through it and then some areas like
the uh
um strikes would happen there was one i
remember there's the strikes that
happened and the [ __ ] cleaners went on
strike for a couple months
and uh the the local government i can't
remember which city it was it might have
been somewhere in scotland
um they still wouldn't yield to the
demands so instead of cleaning it higher
in the guys back to clean the [ __ ] out
they just put a new road above the [ __ ]
so now you had an underground
yeah so they just that might have been
edinburgh
yeah so now you had an underground thing
with a phil [ __ ] horse [ __ ] and all
kinds of criminals and hookers down in
there
and and
then there was a new pile of [ __ ] going
on
it took [ __ ] on top of [ __ ] [ __ ] on top
of [ __ ] it's like a [ __ ] sandwich yeah
it took a while to [ __ ] work
something out and then and that remember
correctly it took two or three years to
finally totally clear the city out
that's right because you have to think
how many people and horses and other
animals like you know chickens and
whatever like live there every single
day everybody just [ __ ] in the road
and just throwing it outside and just
throwing it outside i mean that would
add up real quick now this goes back to
mary shelley and all these people you
know um
one of the big reasons why the
colonization of the new world had
happened with these british and european
colonies that were appearing in the new
world in america was to get out of this
to get out of that situation
the living was a lot cleaner in the
frontier a lot cleaner
so they were trying to get out of those
cities they were pretty bad and the and
the chaos was bad in those cities so was
the crime people don't realize
there was no [ __ ] law enforcement
or i mean there was but they really
didn't have any it was moderate official
yeah it's like basically down you could
do whatever you wanted i mean basically
we're gonna walk around and like hey if
you're murdering somebody hey you
knocked that off yeah yeah yeah no real
law enforcement
that's all they could do and they didn't
really i mean they didn't even have
fingerprinting
until the very late 19th century he had
witnesses
and a lot of times the witnesses they
did have were fingering somebody who was
innocent
because you can
because you're somebody you didn't like
you're just like hey this [ __ ] i
saw him like murdering somebody or you
could pay false witnesses to accuse an
enemy of yours yeah
there's a bunch of weird [ __ ] you could
they were doing back then they were
crooked
but there was
body thief body snatching going on and
selling bodies
yeah we kind of want to get the results
all kinds of [ __ ] happening um and then
there was people murdering other people
to sell their bodies there were whole
gangs that did that
well yeah burke and hare probably the
most famous uh who started out as grave
robbers but then they were like hey
let's cut out the middle man and just
start like murdering people
yeah we can get more money that way well
you know that's the logical conclusion
europe and certain places were building
cities before they had the
same with america before they had their
[ __ ] together before they had the
technological the level of technology
and organizations that you would need to
run a city it was kind of like an
accident
yeah it was an accident it's something
that grew just because there was
something and they had to figure stuff
out as they went along right no central
planning yeah because i think even the
romans had that the romans definitely
had central planning yeah they were
running aqueducts and all kinds of [ __ ]
yeah because really if you're gonna have
a city the size of london let's say
because that's a massive [ __ ] city uh
you really need to like uh think about
that before you start like where's all
these people's [ __ ] gonna go where's the
clean water gonna come from so yeah but
like you said it happened over centuries
and no one was really uh playing some
people are anarchists they don't believe
in any kind of government oh well it'll
all just work itself out no won't go
back
i don't believe in big [ __ ]
overarching governments but local
governments like city government you
need organizations
if that many people are gonna live in
one there's just too many there's too
many logistics you need a water
department too many things that need to
be taken care of who's gonna take the
garbage away who's gonna take care of
all this power production you need a
bunch of [ __ ] you do need security you
need police
posses or militias or armies and things
to keep outsiders out to keep bad things
from happening from within you do need
i don't i i agree with the anarchists
though there should not be
like overreaching government there
shouldn't be that
they shouldn't be telling you what
you're gonna do per se with your life or
your body
it's just that if you're going to live
in a city you have to help on the
infrastructure so you should pay taxes
for water service or pay the bill for
the water yeah because everybody
benefits from that right you pay the
water bill like i said as long as what
you're doing with your life or your body
isn't hurting anybody else right then
yeah that shouldn't be anything now if
if your [ __ ] is like affecting other
people then yeah like a hoarder [ __ ]
hoarding [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up
making rats and attacking the
neighborhood yeah because you're
affecting your whole entire neighborhood
that's to be sanitation standards yeah
um you know we all kind of have to agree
on that so i do agree i'm not yeah i'm
not one of those people it's like oh
just let anybody do whatever the [ __ ]
they want because yeah that's not gonna
work out no not gonna work out you have
to have there has to be order yeah
that's that's basically like i said
there has to be some semblance of
you know we we all have to agree on you
know can we have please like clean
streets can no one like poop in the
streets and stuff like that which like i
said it took us
upsettingly long to figure out right
which factory goes wrong is when they
start telling you
what to believe what to think who you're
[ __ ] what kind of drugs you're gonna
take what you're gonna buy that's none
of their business
yeah like i said as long as as long as
your choices are not affecting other
people or you know society at large
protect the common good the common piece
yeah then other than that i don't like i
said you can [ __ ] whoever you want you
can just you know it's your body put
drugs in it if you want to it's you know
i'm not really worried about it like i
said
you know and we've talked about this
before
um you know i
think that all drugs should be legalized
however i don't think that anybody
should be able to like drive a [ __ ]
car on public roads [ __ ] up on stuff
but it's just like alcohol yeah so so
you know to an extent yeah as long as
you're staying in your own house right
do whatever the [ __ ] you want i don't
care but if you're going out like
affecting the public then yeah that
should be a society that prevents
freedom but responsibility you can't do
all this [ __ ] but if you [ __ ] over other
people because by doing it then you're
liable yeah you can't go out and [ __ ]
take lsd and then drive down the [ __ ]
freeway at 110. you could no yeah that
that's just looks dude totally not bad
so you have people that try to argue for
or get certain things using extreme no
it has to be common sense yeah just
compensation which like i said you know
it's do what you want as long as you're
not as long as you say [ __ ] over
other people
mango says drude is a kraken novel it is
indeed uh i'm really enjoying re-reading
it second time because remember i said i
read it a couple years back like i think
a year or two after i came out and i
loved it so i'm rereading it for the
show so i'm gonna sit down by the
mexican border having a hard time he's
gonna keep refreshing the chat oh [ __ ]
bee's nest is one of them is my uh
physical education student he's getting
swallowed
getting swell
looking good
scott says amsterdam used to have [ __ ]
barges that would go from house to house
along a canal and empty their latrine
pits at night yeah
yeah you had um what did they used to
call it i remember reading a book about
this because that's this is the kind of
thing that i read books about
and um
what did they call it they called the
poop they had like a euphemism for it
night soil
night soil so you would have like these
kind of you know it was obviously the
lower class people but people that
needed a job and they go around to
people's houses and collect all the [ __ ]
from their overnight you know their
chamber pots
and a lot of them would like dig through
it like it was once it had been like
dumped in the sewers you'd get kind of
like people digging through it like
looking for valuables and stuff the old
south used to have hooker ships
going up and down the mississippi river
big old paddle boats field hookers
and it was kind of like a mobile hooker
hotel
and it would stop off at a port and all
the hookers would go out and he was a
party and then yeah it's like the hooker
party barge yeah they didn't get back on
the bars and go to the next and they
were kind of being banished it's like a
cruise in reverse yeah but what's funny
is like nobody wanted them no none of
the [ __ ] local
nobody wanted none of the local
governments wanted them so they were
constantly jumping from one port to the
next and trying to do it apply the trade
secretly before there was a government
that's actually a pretty good idea
because you're getting less trouble
probably doing that than if you tried to
set up a state so you had to be moving
constantly moving and you jump out and
the local authorities you could bribe
them evidently what was going on they
weren't supposed to have that thing
[ __ ] in the port
but for a certain amount of money they
might give it 24 hours
that's evidently yeah and they'll just
be we'll just pretend we didn't see the
[ __ ] yeah yeah we'll respond tomorrow
yeah yeah thank you chi-ching you know
yeah there was a lot of that [ __ ] a lot
of that that was another book i read too
about like a lot of the uh the whole
brothel scene like in england
and it was fascinating i mean all that
kind of [ __ ] is like fascinating to me
all that kind of like
i love all this sorted history yeah like
stuff they don't
this w wouldn't maybe uh necessarily
think of or you know that they don't
really teach you in school um but i like
all those little hidden byways of
history which like i said i think is why
i'm so into this story
so all right so um stop prop says ever
been outside cbgb yeah that place is a
[ __ ] yeah it's not it they closed it
now right gone now yeah i think it's
gone out that's oh well end of an era
but yeah
that was kind of the whole that was one
of the appeals of it though was that it
was such a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah dog
[ __ ] on the floor and stuff yeah well
you know punk rockers yeah all your
crust punks they were into it probably
or pretended they were during the time i
was in there they didn't have a dog [ __ ]
though that was like way back in the day
well at least they at least they cleaned
up the dog there was a much better place
in detroit it was called [ __ ] um
[ __ ] city club i like city club it
was a lot better
city club st andrews hall there's
another one was good
beezness says i sell cadavers as a side
job
well you know someone's got to
so all right so mary shelley
was actually born in 1797. now you have
to think around this time period
this was i kind of feel like like i said
we talk about enlightenment we talk
about like the you know the scientific
revolution all that kind of stuff
something that was going on a lot in
this time period before they had
completely understood
the nature of life um you know this was
prior to charles darwin's you know
origin of species prior to a lot of
things so i kind of feel like one of the
big things at this point everyone was
really interested in biology
and they were interested in maybe we'll
be able to like reanimate the dead so i
kind of feel like that was something
that was at least in intellectual
circles and scientific circles was
something that
they thought was um
a pretty uh like
that seemed like something that could be
done because electricity
and magnetism and stuff like that no one
really understood what its implications
like what its full implications were
yeah they were shocking little frog legs
and [ __ ] the frog legs would start
kicking it they would even shock [ __ ]
dead bodies of humans they'd start
moving yeah and what was funny is that
on a side note
the japanese knew about this they were
writing about it and talking about it
back in japan and they were tripping the
[ __ ] out
well uh what white people were doing
with damn electricity and dead bodies
and there was a japanese offshoot of
that imagine that
they're hearing about it and they're
imagining what evidently there's like
japanese like what the [ __ ] are they
doing over there
they're
traumatizing it and [ __ ] you know
i'd imagine they tripped the [ __ ] out in
japan
yeah they probably did yeah well i mean
mary shelley she was a kid around this
time period and like i said because her
parents were
um very well known like in intellectual
circles they were both philosophers and
writers um so she actually you know in
her household there were a lot of you
know intellectuals like philosophical
thinkers scientists stuff like that so
she would have been even when she was a
kid she would have been privy to all of
these sort of like uh conversations
about what was going on in the
scientific establishment at the time and
as i said one of the big things was the
powers of electricity powers magnetism
and one of the things they were talking
about is that maybe uh through
electricity and magnetism uh we can
reanimate the dead and like you said
there had been some experiments uh
galvani was doing the experiments with
frog legs yeah and they would shock the
frogs like they would move and like
nobody understood
you know they didn't really understood
that was just like a nerve you know the
frog is still dead obviously um but they
thought well movement that equals life
yeah right so they thought oh my god
we're gonna like bring some [ __ ] back
from the dead so you they would do it
like you know that murderers or whatever
would get like hanged and then they
would do experiments on them like in
front of big
you know uh things full of like
audiences full of people and they'd be
like look and they chugging their arms
would move and they may be like
you know what i mean you brought him
back from the dead oh my god it's like
man's usurping the power of god so it
was just kind of like this big
idea that was kind of around at the time
you know yeah and it was going worldwide
yeah now when the japanese found about
it it might have been it was probably it
was going to probably be after the
oliver perry [ __ ] thing when japan
opened up but
i saw
people talking about in excerpts from
the books that they wrote about this
kind of [ __ ]
it was probably decades later but the
japanese were still they were tripping
over that
yeah imagine that
i can't imagine people in another
culture are trying to bring back the
dead that blow your [ __ ] mind if
you're japanese you know what i mean
well it must it seemed to be blowing
europeans behind you because everybody
was like talking about it right it
seemed like a big like topic of
discussion at the time that we can just
like apply some uh this magical
electricity this new this newfangled
thing
and uh it looks like we're bringing dead
bodies back to life and like the
implications of that must have been like
really mind-blowing even though
obviously we know nowadays that that
wasn't what was happening but they
didn't know so it seemed like a really
big deal so that's something that was
like really in the culture at the time
that a lot of people close to what was
happening i mean it's it's
electrochemical
yeah you put a [ __ ] you put a [ __ ]
send a [ __ ] electricity through any
muscle mass
in the on the nerves it'll [ __ ]
twitch but that's not the same as life
for the [ __ ] what's happening inside
the mind
yeah exactly like i said it's just like
a bodily it doesn't have anything to do
with um i think we like blick glitched
out a little bit but i think we're okay
now right here um uh dj maniac who comes
in saying first even though we've been
on for an hour yeah she's very very fun
he also says your kids are coming to see
me next month which kids would talk
about a starry night oh
those kids
said make sure to uh
tell them we said hi
that's pretty awesome we just saw them
at the uh absolutely what city is that
where where are they going
yeah where is that are they going to the
they going over to uh i don't remember
where where um i knew they played in
germany and [ __ ] like that a lot of
times they did like a tour over there a
couple years back yeah
so okay so as i said mary's oh okay yeah
new york city all right okay
that's pretty cool yeah they put on a
good show they do tell them i get pissed
their sets aren't quite long enough but
you know we always [ __ ] at them but
they i don't know they're just kind of
probably like one we don't play want to
play that long and two it's like it's
better to like leave people yeah wanting
more than
like [ __ ] get off they got three
albums and it's all [ __ ] every one of
those albums is good man they could get
up there and play for [ __ ] two hours
so i'd [ __ ] love it yeah yeah they
probably don't want to do that no they
don't want to
[Laughter]
i can't believe them
but yeah so like i said so mary was born
in 1797 so her dad
was uh william godwin who was a very
well-known radical philosopher a bit of
an anarchist i don't know if i'd say
anarchist but
he was very into
like revolutionary like i said very
anti-authority very anti-religion
um you know kind of
i guess what you call at least back in
those days a libertarian sort of thing
where uh he was very into like
individual individual rights uh rights
of women stuff like that uh you know
which kind of big deal at the time so um
he actually wrote uh a book
about
essentially like equality like everyone
should have the same access to justice
and stuff again a very revolutionary
idea for the time and uh that was kind
of like among british radicals that was
kind of like a really one of one of
their big uh textbooks a lot of that
[ __ ] was linked up with kind of like
free well you'd take it for granted but
like
what they call free love movements women
should have rights they should have the
right to keep with [ __ ] that's what
they're talking about because they
couldn't they didn't back then
yeah a woman couldn't have sex with you
not without her father's permission
well both um [ __ ] like that you're like
wait a minute what mary shelley's mother
and her father were both advocates of
free love they were they were
they were anti-marriage
in principle yeah they said you don't
have to although they were married yeah
they they were very much against uh you
know they were basically like you do you
kind of thing yeah so it's a very you
know the modern
when you say free love or women's rights
it's a very it has a very different
flavor when you hear that with modern
ears you have to [ __ ] go back in time
and see what how women lived back then
you'd know exactly what they were
talking about a woman should have a
right to sleep wherever she wants to she
had the right she should have the right
to make a living to [ __ ] get a job
which she couldn't which they could back
then nobody should have the right to own
a house and have a bank which you
couldn't back you couldn't back them in
the u.s they were not allowed to a
married woman could not have a bank
account or a credit card in just her
name until 1974.
yeah
in my that's in my lifetime that's in
your lifetime yeah
it seems insane that is insane yeah that
is insane but it was just kind of
considered for a long time even though
this wasn't even the reality on the
ground even back in the exalted 50s
because most women actually did have to
work
but the way that it was set up
um was that they you were expected to
you know marry a man and the man was
supposed to support you you were
supposed to keep your house and raise
kids and [ __ ] like that and it was not
so it wasn't really um there there
wasn't really much mechanism in the
culture at large for women to make their
own way so if like if your husband died
or left you or something like that you
were kind of [ __ ]
so the women's rights movements of the
17 and 1800s by today's standards were
extreme common sense
extreme comments yeah by today's
standards everyone's like
but back then it was like a big deal i
mean that was something that like nobody
was talking about because everyone just
considered that women
didn't need to be educated they didn't
they just needed to be married off and
then they were supposed to like just
keep house and have kids yeah for a man
that a woman should have the right to to
to choose who she marries that's another
one because they mostly didn't the
dad said yeah they kind of set them all
up yeah not exactly arranged marriages
but sometimes they were they kind of
were in in practice not gonna lie
you could buy a daughter basically yeah
you could buy a man's daughter dowries
and weird things like that yeah
particularly in the upper middle class
to upper class that was if you were a
really rich guy and you wanted
somebody's young daughter you were going
to get her especially if she was poor
yeah yeah because she didn't have a
choice no you could go in there and buy
her basically you when the family liked
you which they would if you had the
money and then you paid the right dial
reasons hook the family up the right way
you'd get the wife
and they the mom would be like oh no
this is for your future you know
they would talk her into it because it
was more about security what about love
it was security yeah and i think even a
lot of marriages that you know were
chosen were not chosen for reasons of oh
i'm in love with this person and i want
to marry them it was all like a business
transaction essentially um you know does
this person have enough money to support
me
in the manner to which i am accustomed
if you go back into the writings of the
time most women were most they were
happiest when they became widows
because they were now free yeah
and um they were actually
free to pursue their own ends
and a lot of them when the husband died
they actually had money and some
security if the guy had hooked her up
right
but
not so much in the working class
actually the poor women were a lot freer
than in some ways yeah you know poor
women were i mean you're not freer
because you're broke and being broke is
its own kind of slavery really but
on the upside nobody cared what you did
that's true so it was kind of like it
was it was a balance right uh so you
know so but if you had money everybody
was absolutely like looking at you and
you could be we got in this before some
of the freest women in the united states
back in the olden days were like
octoroon quadrant women black women
and indian women
people and have to play by white people
and like i said i was uh reading a
couple books about uh essentially the
history of prostitution actually during
this time period in the uk um you know
the women that were the freest uh from
today's uh perspective would have been
women that owned brothels yeah um and
women that worked in brothels yeah i
mean you know maybe not a great life if
you didn't choose that but they actually
could do pretty much whatever they
wanted and they could operate within
higher social circles
with
they had a whiff of
kind of like the society ladies
obviously would look down on them but
they could pretty much do whatever they
want
yeah they could pretty much do whatever
they want they could own property they
had their own money um you know and they
were kind of they didn't have to like
listen to no man like telling them what
to do and [ __ ] like that louisiana
[ __ ] octoroon quadroon uh women were
the geisha of the [ __ ] of america
and uh there's portraits of them they
had a lot of money they had a lot of
power they're powerful friends
um they were kind of like the rock stars
same thing with some of those women for
the steamboat type women and
uh if you were a modern woman and you
had to go back to a [ __ ] time machine
to the [ __ ] 18 1700s
when you got back there [ __ ] really
the only thing you would
that you would ever consider would be
that lifestyle you wouldn't want any of
the others yeah i wouldn't really wanna
i don't think i could live under those
constraints um i mean it's interesting
because in france at least i'm not sure
if they call it this in other places but
they actually had a word for this it's
called demi monde which is like half
world so it's almost like it was like a
subculture um and these were people that
could operate at several different
layers of society and they like i said
they had a whiff of indiscretion about
them like they couldn't be seen at the
best places and everything because
everyone would be like oh and they'd all
cluck at them
but
in practice i mean they were pretty free
to like operate essentially as they
wished which a lot of people were not
and what's funny is that the difference
between these demi mon and the real rich
guys especially young real rich guys was
about nil that was almost the same scene
and a lot of interestingly a lot of
women that
started out as prostitutes and then went
on to become like brothel owners uh
particularly in the uk like became very
very wealthy and also uh had their own
like salons so they would have like all
these like so they were kind of up in
the scene like all the intellectuals you
know the writers and painters and [ __ ]
like that so they were kind of like in
the center of all the [ __ ] that was like
lawmakers and powerful politician type
guys too yeah that too they had their
fingers and all that and [ __ ]
organized crime yep that was the
go-betweens for
the political class and the oligarch
class and organized crime they all knew
the same
madams
because you have to think that was like
the only really that was the only legit
path of women to power right in that
time period because like i said for most
women
you couldn't really have your own money
you couldn't really have
you couldn't have a life of your own
really you're always kind of like
attached to somebody else i mean
obviously there was exceptions to that
but
you know if you just came from the
working classes or you came from you
know somewhere where you didn't have
family money
uh you had to like make your own [ __ ]
way somehow
and
that's how some women did it and i don't
blame them in the least in a way though
um the madams and the brothel women were
kind of like uh
the
one of the greatest examples of natural
selection really
because
the best kind of rose to the top so in a
way it was kind of like uh
it's kind of like they had earned their
positions they weren't born with them
well yeah because like i said most of
them came from the working classes and
they just kind of they were savvy enough
yeah character wise they would have been
[ __ ] quite cool
yeah and that's the impression i got to
like from at least like in a day the
ones that i read about yeah so so yeah
so william godwin like i said that was
her dad and he was um very ahead of his
time in thinking that women should also
be educated just as men should he didn't
really seem to think uh that women were
any lesser or they were less intelligent
or anything like that so he took great
pains even though mary shelley
didn't have a great deal of formal
education he took great pains to he
opened up his library to her he let her
be privy to all of these you know other
intellectuals that came and uh hung out
at the you know their house and um he
got her tutors and things like that so
she was uh very much educated uh beyond
what a
what a typical woman at the time would
have been uh educated by
also her mother
uh mary or uh rather wait where was i oh
mary wollstonecraft
um
probably i guess you could call her the
founder of feminism really uh she
actually wrote a book a vindication of
the rights of woman which is actually
still taught in colleges to this day
and sounds actually pretty modern uh to
our eyes but yeah she
was very much on the cutting edge of
absolutely believing that women were
equal in every way to men and uh should
be treated as such
so it makes sense because over here in
the united states especially back in the
17 16 17 1500s 16 17 1800s you kind of
had to get it as you lived
so it was all about practicality a lot
of these old rules just they didn't work
they couldn't work in in the new world
yeah i mean like i said i well the thing
and this kind of happens uh you know in
general is that
i think that people's attitudes and
stuff like that um you know the the
greater culture is always kind of like
lagging behind a little bit it's like
they're behind right yeah well because
it takes a long time for a mechanism to
like catch up to it
so even though i mean you have to think
this is way before
i mean this is like the like 1800 we're
talking about and mary wollstonecraft is
talking about you know how she thought
that women should have the same rights
as men which you know not a lot of
people were talking about it's a very
kind of fringe
uh you know
belief at the time
and this was even way before like the
suffragette movement all of that kind of
stuff because in case you didn't know
like i think this it happened quicker in
europe but even women didn't even have
weren't even allowed to vote in the u.s
until 1920 1921
uh not really that long my grandmother
was alive
uh when that happened so that's not
really that long ago i think europe was
quicker
uh depending on whatever country you're
talking about but
even back in 1800 uh mary wollstonecraft
was talking about
you know obviously women should have the
same rights as men one of the quotes
that i liked from her
uh she said this was uh from her book
she says from the tyranny of man i
firmly believe the greater number of
female follies proceed
let women share the rights and she will
emulate the virtues of man for she must
grow more perfect when emancipated so
she's basically saying all the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] you don't like about women is just
caused by men like crushing them under
their heel basically and if they were
freed they would act just the same well
they didn't have to do anything yeah
they didn't have to do much does that
make me do laundry
raise children although that's [ __ ]
tough well back in those days that was
like even worse like nowadays it's
that's nothing it's kind of shitty and
you know it took all day to do laundry
back then it did because nobody had
washing machines or dishwashers or
anything you had to do everything by
hand unless you had servants which a lot
of people did not
uh so interestingly even though like i
said both mary wollstonecraft and um
william godwin were kind of
like i said in principle they were kind
of against marriage they were married um
but they i don't know if they were
they just kind of felt like it was if it
was forced on people then um
then it was not good because it was like
a form of slavery type of thing yeah but
they were married they were like star
trek before star trek they were
you're captain kirk back in the 60s
saying this [ __ ] well you know we get
married you get married you know it
doesn't matter
[ __ ] in the original star trek they
they're actually espousing
things that they're just dreaming about
in their in the 18 in 1816 yeah yeah
honestly it must have been really shitty
to have these attitudes back then
um because where you were depending on
where you were because really i mean
it's kind of like nowadays it's like no
like you know it's it's nothing because
most people are like there were three
love communes in the 1800s
there was all kinds
and it was a sparsely populated area you
could always find like mines
and that's probably what was going on
and there wasn't a social media the
world was a lot smaller than
if you ended up in a place i don't know
like the french quarter and with an
apartment there you'd probably have a
[ __ ] good time and live your whole
life as a woman and not really be
impeded by any of this
because yeah that area was
like a
free and neutral zone
yeah you know
now would it be like that out on a
prairie somewhere no [ __ ] no but what
would you be doing down there
you know yeah
surviving on the prairie yeah so
i think uh
even though the system was [ __ ] up
there was a lot of different
environments to choose from
you could find your place in the world
even if that meant joining the indian
tribes which a lot of women did a lot of
white women joined in the intro like i
said can't say i blame them and that was
a lot better life than living on the
city it was mobile and uh that was
that was kind of like uh
women's liberation in a way
to be a tribal woman they didn't have
those same restrictions
they did have gender roles but the
gender roles were kind of empowered with
uh native americans to a certain state
well i kind of feel like they were more
like well we're all in this together and
we just got to like work to do whatever
has to be done and they weren't really
worried about
they weren't worried as much about well
the woman's got to do this yeah man's
got to do that it's just well
something's got to be done somebody do
it it was tribal somebody do it we don't
care who right yeah
well it was tribal it was just tribal
customs and it was being real practical
that was always been said over and over
again about most of those native
american tribes is that it's more about
practicality that's what i'm saying
getting [ __ ] done it's more like just
getting [ __ ] done i don't care who does
it right doesn't have to be a boy thing
or a girl thing just somebody please
[ __ ] do it you know what i'm saying
well it depends
there was strict gender roles with
indian tribes dudes had to have warrior
virtues they had to hunt they had to go
to war
um there were certain festivals that
they had to take part in so no they had
a real macho side to that but they oh
you know india and evidently femininity
was you know about children and
supporting the family unit and you know
it was but it was reasonable they
weren't saying you couldn't survive on
your own
there wasn't a lot yeah see i think
that's where because obviously there are
biological differences obviously like
the big one obviously women can bear
children and men cannot um i you know i
don't think there are as many
differences as people uh
make it out to be but obviously that's a
big difference so there is going to be
some little physiological difference
there but the problem i have arises when
because i kind of feel like and you see
this a lot in like particularly
victorian and this kind of era is that
because femininity was seen as like
something different they always saw it
as something lesser like women well they
don't need to be educated or they're
more emotional or they're dumber or
something like that they always they
never saw it as like
just different but but equal
it was always like it's not as good
that it just it always kind of like came
across like that to me garden of eden
stories had a lot to do with that well
oh yeah women came women were made from
adam adam was the standard yeah so
therefore the standard by which all
humans were judged were by men
basically yep women weren't as strong
they weren't as big
and in the greek age weren't as
good-looking even though they didn't
believe in those same things but you
know yeah um
so
yeah what you're saying i think is is
true
it's just that you can't really take it
and run with it and generalize because i
don't think all men bought into that
either no i'm not saying they did i'm
just saying that the prevailing
attitudes of the time at least from the
writings and [ __ ] like that that have
survived that's one thing that really
sticks out to me
is that femininity was also was always
seen as distinct but also lesser than i
like to use the old west
uh examples you know doc holliday and
all those guys that would hang out in
those [ __ ] towns
all of them were in love with hookers
famous hookers they called them stars
back then because they had a star and
they would go up and sing and do shows
which justified why they were hookers i
guess you could say they didn't want to
be hookers but women women don't want to
be hookers
generally no they're i mean there are
exceptions to that there are to
everything but in general no no it's not
but that was the situation of the day
that was yeah that was more freedom than
they would have had had they been
married to some jackal back in a
dumbbell tenement in new york in the
1800s they were living the life in
misery been to get them okay
so they kept little french poodles and
bought little fine things and sang on
stage and got uh got all the props from
the crowd and they were very popular and
then they uh they
sold their wares to the highest
you know customers but they always had a
boyfriend
and most of those gunfighters
were like the boyfriends okay
uh which is funny but i guess they knew
the deal she had to make a living
somehow yeah
and like i said there weren't a lot of
avenues open a lot of averages open so
evidently they did [ __ ] have they
were not conventional relationships but
i think they were very human and
conventional emotions going on it's just
that they're in a frontier situation
yeah and she has to make a living and he
can't support her through a life of
[ __ ] crime or gunfighting or whatever
and you know maybe she's not really
eligible for marriage because of her
her
her yeah she'd be like uh i can't really
marry her but i do love her that kind of
i think they did love those girls
because they [ __ ] killed dudes over
them yeah you know
and uh got offended and [ __ ] when uh the
wrong customer wanted to do business
with them and stuff so
no there were emotions there
yeah so
i don't know i'm just saying
not all dudes and evidently dudes
thought that what was going on was
[ __ ] up with the women too oh yeah and
i and i'm sure that they were yeah i'm
just saying that that was the prevailing
culture of the time i'm not saying that
everyone bought into it because
absolutely they didn't yeah there's a
lot of evidence based on [ __ ]
testimony at the time
that even the macho men of the time
which would have been gun fighters and
[ __ ] um um lawmen did not really like
what what society was pushing on them
it was just that was the society they
were born with yeah and there didn't
seem to be any avenues to change it yeah
you just kind of had to evolve slowly
yep
and really if you go back in history it
didn't really change until world war ii
that's what i'm saying so that's what
kind of sucks you live back then and
you're very aware
of how [ __ ] up [ __ ] is yeah but you're
powerless and you can't really do
anything about it and there aren't
really a lot of other people who share
your point of view or at least it seems
that way um and it so there don't really
seem to be any avenues open to you to
like do anything to change it so you're
just kind of like stuck in this
perpetual japan's the same way japan
japanese spent a lot of time complaining
about japan but they don't seem to have
any ability to change it
i mean it's hard for like just a couple
of people to change something but the
thing is i think it's a large percentage
of the [ __ ] japanese population don't
really like about certain things that
happen in japan especially in tokyo but
they're powerless to change it because
it's their culture they don't want us to
be the first one to stand up
yeah that's weird
well you know you're the first one to
stand up you're going to get like
hammered yeah right here probably what
they're always afraid of yeah which
that's usually what happens to the first
person that stands up and said hey this
is [ __ ] up right you really need a lot
of people to stand up and wants to go
hey this is [ __ ] up take something
that you can't do which is a [ __ ]
basically a calamity in a certain stance
but it's also a rebirth
yeah but it's also the beginning of
empire it becomes very much like the
roman empire after that yeah over time
oracle says bram stoker's mother was an
early feminist too she famously said
that the first step to curing the
world's ills was equalized sexes so yeah
there was a lot of this [ __ ] going on in
the zeitgeist it took a long time
uh for anything to come about because of
it but
all these uh women back then they knew
the [ __ ] was [ __ ] up man and they were
like brave enough to like [ __ ] talk
about it grampa's hammer says which is
worse draconian 18th century attitudes
about women or the current mgtow
movement i would argue that the 18th
century attitudes were way worse because
the big town uh at least like i said men
going their own way i'm like bye they're
separatists go yeah they're not trying
to make it no one's going to miss you
yeah i mean i know that you think that
they will but they won't just go away i
don't think that's what they're thinking
no i'm just i'm just saying that i i
just think that check it out all right
all right bye like i said dudes have a
right to not deal with women you can't
force a dude to deal with women no i
wouldn't i would never imagine that they
because i don't want to have to be
forced to deal with dudes either right
so it's like if you want to go just go
right i am not if you don't know you
sound you sound like a sperm lover no
i'm just saying
no i'm just saying that i'm not affected
in the slightest right they're not
trying to affect anybody well that's
good that's why you're saying it is the
mgtow thing would be better because the
myth that's what i said they're not
they're not they're not forcing their
[ __ ] unfortunately to comply to anything
they're just going this is hopeless and
then they're checking out yeah now do i
believe that it's helpless
depends on who you are if i were to see
them guys and see their habits i look at
them yeah you are hopeless
that might be so that might be the best
strategy for them
is it hopeless for a popular [ __ ]
uh uh a young male who has a promising
future no it's not hopeless are you
talking about no
[ __ ] no
drop your nuts get out there and compete
man go [ __ ] get with some women bill
just but here's the deal and jenny saw
me do this this dude
i had this young guy who was
[ __ ] going out with this stripper
that we know he was a good-looking guy
and she's real cute well she ended up
dumping him and well he was living off
of her he was just a young guy with no
nothing under his belt
and i was talking to him and he i could
tell he was devastated
and i said well how old are you well i
just turned you know 20.
he says what do you do dude
and i said well man
when i was your age i wouldn't join the
army i want to get a job
yeah you think i lived here in this
[ __ ] nightclub go out and do
something nobody else wants to do a life
of adventure something that's hard
something that you make a lot of money
at
and [ __ ] that [ __ ] vanished
didn't see him for a couple years later
when he came back the [ __ ]
looked grisly as [ __ ] and he's like and
he came up and shake my hand he says
thank you for that talk you gave me i
said where you been and he goes i did
exactly what you said man i joined a
company i work i live on an offshore oil
rig see there you go because i'm making
so much money now [ __ ] it every time i
come in [ __ ] he goes i got i got i
can back my [ __ ] up now and when i get
done man i have a lot of money buying a
house i'm doing this and that and he
goes i never would have done that it
says i would have rested back and just
try to mooch off these [ __ ] hot girls
see that's not your problem yeah
and this is why
and this is why we we might have covered
this a little bit on the incel show i
kind of feel like most of these dudes
that are like incels and they're
constantly whining about how women will
sleep with them i was like dude you
can't just like sleep on a couch in your
mom's basement and play video games all
day and expect hot girls to jump on your
dick that's not how it works [ __ ] works
no go get a job go be interesting yeah
go do something do something that makes
you interesting dude came in he's like
22 [ __ ] buffed out man of the sea
grizzly looking and [ __ ] [ __ ] looked
like a real warrior he'd been living
working
he's been spending i think it was six
months out of the year on that offshore
oil rig making like 150 000 a year on
that oil rig see there you go and
[ __ ] came in with some swag
as a young man that's all like i said
nobody is telling and like don't and
honestly don't do it because you want to
get [ __ ] do it because you want to you
want to improve yourself yeah improve
yourself that's what i told him
everybody everybody should do that yeah
men women i don't care who you are i
said you need to work on your own [ __ ]
just worry about yourself yeah and i
said all that other [ __ ] will take care
of itself right
exactly because they don't want to be
just [ __ ] you can't just expect
to just lay around and be this lazy bomb
that doesn't have any anything
interesting or anything they don't
create anything magic dick yeah it's
like no one is i'm sorry but like as a
woman no
no dick is worth that yeah sorry no dick
is worth putting up with that crap his
little 135 pound ass came back at
[ __ ] like a hundred and eighty
[ __ ] was
with his little [ __ ] beard and
[ __ ] man in the cd [ __ ] coming in you
know kind of like that dude from jaws
it's like he's like quinn like quit from
jaws yeah
a dog
is like a dog
god damn i love josh all right yeah
beezness says i want hot girls to jump
on my dick i have to pay for mexicans it
wears off
yeah you know it's
like i said
you gotta worry
is she in this yeah she likes that uh
sink for some reason yeah
i find her in there she just like chills
she's like what it's pookie size it's
exactly pookie's eyes so that's what
this is so yeah so we were talking about
mary shelley's mom so like i said her uh
her books she had written several and
she had a lot of followers i guess you
call them but uh you know she had kind
of like a circle around her and so in a
way these two like william god godwin
and mary wilson craft were kind of like
uh like a power couple in sort of like
the intellectual free love
revolutionary type circles of the day
now sadly uh mary wollstonecraft she
gave birth to mary shelley in 1797
and shortly after she gave birth to her
she developed um what they would call a
child bed fever or something like that
basically it's um
a postpartum infection of the birth
canal which was very very common uh in
this era obviously because no one was
washing their [ __ ] hands so you know
it was like a yeah well it was just a
dirty business childbirth um and they
didn't really they weren't super up on
the sanitation standards at the time uh
mary wollstonecraft gave birth to mary
shelley at home as most people did back
then
and sadly mary sheller's mary shelley's
mother died 11 days after giving birth
to her so one thing that mary shelley
had even like even from childhood
was she had this lingering guilt that
she had essentially killed her mother
even though obviously it wasn't her
fault
um
but i don't know if that ever left her
another thing too was that her mom
was
you know as beloved as her mother was
and she was beloved um her father as
well
by you know just their circles at large
um i kind of feel like
her mom also was had kind of like a
melancholy
sort of disposition which mary shelley
also inherited
uh so
you know that's that's always going to
make life harder for you and like i said
if her mom died in childbirth she never
really knew her she was only 11 days old
when her uh mom died
now so basically william godwin as i
said um
you know because he didn't really have
any of the sort of antiquated uh you
know gender attitudes of the time um he
made damn sure that mary was educated uh
way beyond what a woman at the time
would have been
um so basically
so he and he had a bunch of uh followers
as well uh as his wife had done
and um you know particularly among the
revolutionaries at the time so he had
kind of like a lot of young
disciples i guess you would call them
one of which
was percy shelley
who at the time he first started
corresponding with william godwin i
believe percy shelley was 21 years old
and he was going to oxford although
eventually he'd be kicked out
because uh
essentially for lots of reasons which
was atheism
uh he was a again another free love
advocate so he had like a lot of ideas
along the same lines as william godwin's
um and so oxford were like yeah get out
of here
so he started corresponding uh with
william godwin as i said when he was 21
years old
um he was against pretty much everything
he was very anti-marriage he was very
anti-church like i said he was very into
like equality for everyone so again very
revolutionary for the time
now interestingly because percy had been
writing letters to william godwin for a
very long time
uh william godwin one thing that he
would do was he would read uh letters
from percy and from others uh to his
family including mary shelley who was
growing up
um so basically by the time mary was a
teenager
she had already like heard a lot about
this percy shelley person and he sounded
like super fascinating
uh so she had heard a lot about him
before they even met each other
now
they ended up meeting each other
in 1814 percy shelley shows up at
william godwin's bookstore that he owned
this was in london's east end
and he had gone there maybe expressly
perhaps
um
to get a glimpse of william godwin's
daughter who he had heard was uh quite
beautiful she was 16 at this time
uh he was 21. like i said it's a little
weird nowadays but not back then not so
much
so they met each other at the bookshop
and immediately papow
these two are kind of like
i mean percy
uh like i said he was very into like
equal rights for women and stuff like
that too so he immediately like um
there was an immediate like affinity
between the two of them he thought she
was just like
super intelligent that they were like
soul mates you know what i mean he was
like immediately they got each other it
was just kind of this thing
uh even though he was she was a little
bit younger but you know
basically um also he was super into like
the ideas of her parents uh so he
thought that it was cool that you know
she kind of shared uh their same beliefs
and uh he also shared those beliefs so
they had a lot in common
now
only problem was
that when percy shelley met mary
wollstonecraft godwin at the bookstore
that fateful day in 1814
percy
already had a wife
uh her name was harriet and she was 18.
now
this was a massive problem for percy
because like i said he's super into free
love right so he's just basically like
yeah i got a wife man big deal i could
just like bang whoever so it's just kind
of this whole thing the free love thing
okay
it you can kind of get
tainted by uh your your your
preconceived notions and try to maybe
like equate that with be it cults or
anything or [ __ ] like that that's not
really what they're talking about now
all right what they're talking about is
dating
okay yeah marriage is something that was
forced on you by your parents a lot of
times you were lucky to be married to
somebody you gave a [ __ ] about
but then when you start thinking about
it that although the person might be a
captive too they're coming from this
civilization
so you and your wife
might want to date other people who are
like you and your wife yeah and as
your alliance in terms of marriage
really isn't under threat because
everybody's all friends anyway nobody's
gonna run off with anybody
and there's nothing happening behind any
other's back they're not it's not
happening behind anybody else's back
everybody knows it might be going on
with you in the room with it
but you're not jealous because
it's all trading and everything it's
just a love fest
so i guess it's kind of like some not
really like the hippies because the
hippies well these [ __ ] didn't
bathe either
[Laughter]
although i think i i think [ __ ] yeah
this is the 1800s yeah i think i think
mary shelley and [ __ ] byron and all
those guys are probably a little bit
cleaner than [ __ ] a hippie of the 70s
those [ __ ] are probably even
dirtier because i think they did [ __ ]
take baths and they did take sponge
baths and [ __ ] and they put on perfume
and they were intelligent enough that he
complained about something he probably
and look at the paintings these all
these people were good-looking
mary shelley looked pretty mary shelley
was actually quite a beautiful woman
yeah she was cute uh her mother was also
quite beautiful yeah so
hard to say and percy uh was pretty
good-looking dude himself yeah lord
byron was a good-looking dude when he
was younger but i think he had gout so
he kind of got fat when he was older
yeah okay so uh that's what i remember
reading that anyway people aged quickly
back then anyway that's true the
nutrition wasn't that great true you we
take so much for granted of today
me at 53 the way i look there would be
nobody in that world
yeah they don't look like they would
look like me they'd all look like wiz
and old yeah oh dodgers and with [ __ ]
teeth missing and
white hair or real fat or [ __ ] dead
if they were
dead
um
and you take me back to the medieval
period they would have been totally
amazed by the fact that i have all my
teeth
which like nowadays it's not that big a
deal because i see people in their 40s
and 50s all the time that you wouldn't
really that don't look like an old
person they just look like oh no we go
to the club and there's [ __ ] women in
their 40s that are just [ __ ] smoking
hot smoking hot
that didn't exist in this era
i doubt it it would have been very very
rare you would have had to have really
really good genetics you just go online
and there are [ __ ] porn star females
in their 50s that are [ __ ] smoking
hot still
it's just that that just did not you
don't realize how much technology and
knowledge have given you
it's just a totally different world it
is totally different world oracle's
talking about oh wait tammy says i try
to tell young girls all the time don't
wait for prince charming take care of
yourself yeah that's like the best
advice for anybody really yeah prince
charming is not gonna be too charming
most of the time
no he might be charming at first and
then he turns out to be like a serial
killer
a lot of times the ones that look like
prince charming you know you're not he's
not you're not the only woman he's
dealing with
yeah you'd be better off a [ __ ] dude
like clint what's his name from jaws
he's like a dog
yeah
the problem what's happening right now
is that we're living in a laptop
generation and most more women are
coming out of colleges than guys are
they're also attending they tend to make
more money than than guys we're talking
about the younger
generation for dating and marriage 20s
and 30s so these women are gonna have to
realize that the dudes they're not gonna
be able to marry a guy richer than them
or even equal to them they're gonna be
marrying a guy from the world but see i
think nowadays like people younger than
us like even me and i was you know i'm
generation x i kind of like figured out
when i was pretty young i'm like look
i'm just gonna have to like take care of
myself mostly it's like it'd be nice if
somebody else came along but i'm not
going to count on that so and i kind of
feel like everybody should sort of go
into it with that yeah but that's that's
not that's not real like cover your own
ass that's not really pretty much
because what's realistic is that there's
a bunch of there's a bunch of
basically young women out there with
college degrees working in offices that
can't find men that's what realism is
and they can't find men because
women have instinctively want to date up
those rich dudes don't want you
i'm just going to tell you the truth
girls those women don't want you but
those dudes don't want you
rich dudes have lots of girlfriends and
they actually go for the hot ones and
the hot ones that are broke
that are [ __ ] they're not
intellectuals guys don't want that they
want a chick with [ __ ]
big rack
a good body it was a lot of fun who
probably did worked as a stripper for a
while that's who they're [ __ ] going
for they don't give a [ __ ] about your
degree they just don't
that's not well like i said i figured
that out with money i figured that out
when i was a teenager yeah because they
don't need your money
and that was in the 80s yeah
a man would actually rather date a woman
who doesn't have much and he feels like
he's saving her that's more of an
instinct well yeah because they feel
useful well that's the man's role yeah
is to help is to help and to save and to
like and to be the hero
so if you're making a bunch of money in
office he doesn't he doesn't see you as
attractive
he he sees he could go down to the biker
bar and [ __ ]
some waitress working big old titty
waitress at [ __ ] 23 working behind
the bar he loves that loves her okay so
it's not it's not about gain for the man
in a material in a money sense so it's
just a very different strategy women
have to realize that if you have money
and you're working in these offices
you're gonna be dating a guy who's poor
unless he's gonna be or he's gonna be
ugly
okay get you a hot poor guy that's what
i'm telling you to do or he's at the
same level
like i said and that i kind of feel like
that's across the board
you know a guy at your same level is
usually going with going out with a poor
girl [ __ ] this is economics has a lot
to do with it because a guy who's making
40 50 000 a year is real attractive to a
girl who's working at
at mcdonald's
you know
she's
he's prince charming
so he doesn't he's not looking for an
equal he's looking to be a hero
that's just a very different strategy
and the guys in the comment section are
going to agree with me
if you're a woman making a bunch of
money you're a young woman you're
looking for a man
i recommend go for a [ __ ] macho dude
who's hot who doesn't have any money but
he's strong and he knows how to fix
things and he can [ __ ] work on your
car and you [ __ ] help him get a
better job and [ __ ] he'll just
run right to that [ __ ] you know that's
just and have fun don't try to think
about it or honestly just be a lesbian
and don't even like worry about any of
this crap whatever honestly whatever um
oracle says midwives versus doctors
midwives tended to wash their hands
before attending someone in labor and
doctors didn't yeah i kind of feel like
there was a lot of that going on too
uh because
well the thing is doctors at the time
were mostly male they didn't have a lot
of experience with women's health and
midwives did because they were just they
weren't really doctors they mostly just
attended births so they had a lot more
experience in that area so maybe that's
why
but uh yeah all right so where was i
okay
so what was i saying so percy was
already buried uh his wife harriet now
we were talking about free love but
harriet
um
she didn't know all this [ __ ] was going
on
now percy and harriet also already had a
kid at this point uh and harriet was
pregnant with another one
so it's not so much because i think
percy's wife i'm not really entirely
sure how he ended up marrying her so
like i said percy was only 21. harry was
18. um which wasn't that's not unusual
for that time it seems very young to us
now
but i don't know if it was necessarily
arranged or anything like that i don't
know if it was
but
harriet
i don't think she was into the whole
free love thing or she didn't know what
was going on because she got like really
bad when she found out she didn't know
all the [ __ ] was going on hold on i must
say something master of none is asking
tom has a good point but when you're
rich for too long of a time don't you
get bored with the type of woman's tom's
describing
my answer is no and brazil would be the
proof
poor people from brazil male or female
come here to florida and [ __ ] do
super well and matter of fact on another
show i told the story in the horse
industry a dude that i knew who was a
groom from hippico paulista in sao paulo
he was just nothing but a groom
married a [ __ ] multi
multi-millionaire's [ __ ] daughter
they own a mansion
it was a two miles away from our old
house
that dude went from nothing to
everything
and and why and this tends to be uh in
in florida you'll see brazilians tend to
marry way up
why
they're charming as [ __ ] they're very
entertaining
no it doesn't get old it gets better
they don't cut they don't have anything
they have a lot of social skills they
look great they know how to entertain
you give them some money they actually
make more they know how to work with
that
so no just because she's poor doesn't
mean you'll get bored with her
no you'll have fun she she might
actually blossom and the dudes do it too
so you don't judge people
by their socio-economic background
it doesn't work that way
okay good it's like look man women will
love if you watch star wars women will
prefer [ __ ] han solo to [ __ ] luke
skywalker any day it's that same thing
okay that's obviously
you sure uh so i'm gonna say jenny let's
get back to the show well uh yeah look
where this thing is damn yeah see damn
you talking about all this [ __ ] and
i'm just like i'm not even like [ __ ]
i'm not even hurt i'm not even
scratching the [ __ ] server that's
what i'm saying goddamn so you haven't
get into the [ __ ] yet okay so uh so yeah
so uh so percy's already married uh has
a kid and his wife is pregnant
but he has decided and mary has also
decided to be fair uh that they are soul
mates um it's a very it's a romeo and
juliet type of situation
um so they start meeting up uh in secret
at st pankar's graveyard which is in
north london which is where um mary
shelley's mother was buried that's where
her grave was
legend has it that mary lost her
virginity in this cemetery i don't know
if it was on her mom's grave because
that would be a little weird but it was
in that cemetery at least at least
that's what the that's what the story
says
now you have to think too that mary
shelley
i know she's only 16 at this point um
but
she had been raised in an atmosphere i
mean both her parents were advocates of
free love uh you know women's rights
everything like that so this wouldn't
have been all that weird to her um yeah
her boyfriend's married
you know but
it's all good it's just sex whatever so
they start meeting in secret like i said
um so basically it's kind of like
i don't know and percy was kind of had a
lot of the same uh beliefs as mary
shelley's parents did so he was very
against marriage even though he was
married um you know so he kind of
thought one of the quotes that i saw of
his uh was marriage
it is as if a dead and living body had
been linked together in loathsome and
horrible communion come on personally
said that so it seems a little i mean
this romantic romantic the romanticism
movement was all about [ __ ] drama
[ __ ] that's kind of why do you think
the gods love these dudes so much
because everything was just
so
over dramatic i mean everything was like
the end of the world so if you read like
and it's like people talk about nowadays
like people being snowflakes or whatever
it's like go back to like read some
victorian era or some like romantic era
literature holy crap these dudes are
like [ __ ] and it was mostly dudes
they were [ __ ] fainting at the
slightest provocation holy [ __ ]
everything was like the world's biggest
deal it's just hilarious but yes like
like stuff nowadays that everyone would
just like let roll off their back back
then it was like a big huge deal
so yeah
um world was smaller back then it was so
everything was just like this big
dramatic
i think they were just like i think it
entertained them
to be outraged to be just yeah
everything they were just having a good
time because it does kind of give you
that serotonin rush doesn't it
like uh to be outraged at something or
everything's like the world's biggest
deal it's like even though it's really
not that big a deal in the grand scheme
of things
so uh so yeah so
i don't know honestly um i don't think
anybody really knows
if mary shelley
when they first started their affair
i don't know if she knew that he was
already married
um when they first started or if he'd
had a kid and another one on the way i
don't i don't know if she knew that or
if she cared
or if it bothered her i'm not really
entirely sure
no one really knows
um
but
interestingly when
mary's dad found out about this
as
radical as progressive as liberal as his
dad was as her dad was
he's still so he's still a dad right and
he's like look my daughter is only 16
and you are 21 and you are already
married and have two kids
this is not kosher at all he was really
mad
and so basically he said you cannot see
him anymore
uh you know which like i said that's a
very dad thing to do
you know whatever your beliefs are well
he's just watching out for the girl
that's what i mean
yeah i don't think it was the age and
that's the thing and percy shelley um
look his poems and [ __ ] like that are
fantastic
um you know and i'm all into like the
atheism and i'm all into that
but he was a little bit of a [ __ ] not as
much of a [ __ ] as lord byron lord byron
was a giant [ __ ] but i mean he was
just like a callous
[ __ ] these dudes kind of had like a
rockstar syndrome they were also they
were very like they had all these big
philosophical ideas but many of them
let's be honest were very self-serving
they were very self-serving that was the
way in they didn't have rock stars yet
this is the prototype of that it was
that same kind of
they thought they were [ __ ] heavy
metal rock stars
essentially they were the rockstars at
the time yeah and lord byron
particularly has been called that yeah
really okay uh because yeah and there
was a lot of that going on so like i
said as much as
i like a lot of these
those dudes ideas
uh and like i said they were very
progressive for the time they were were
very liberal for the time they were very
anti-religion they were very into like
the rights of women and stuff like that
but
they also there was a kind of a darker
side of that it would which you see like
we've talked about this you see a lot of
a lot of cult leaders
where
in some ways they're just kind of like
oh everybody should be free to do this
and that and basically what they mean is
they should all be free to jump on my
dick and i should be free to be able to
do what i want but y'all can't well
you're saying they're liberal and
progressive by today's standards with it
but actually no by the days well by what
by what they did
by what they wrote yeah and for the time
but by today's standards they've just
been dudes they've been yeah pretty
regular dudes there's a lot of guys like
yeah so they basically are just kind of
like
i don't know they're floating on being
what we would call normal in a way
they're getting famous just for having
deep common sense
like let let a woman have a job if she
wants it well that wasn't common sense
back then though
because everybody's like what woman
women they can't do anything so they get
they're getting kind of they can't think
yeah they're getting kind of famous
they're not as good they're kind of
getting famous by just uh having common
sense but it go it's going to their
heads
yeah oh definitely yeah so like i said
i'm willing to give them some leeway
because of the time they grew up in but
uh that doesn't mean they weren't dicks
because they were oh yeah um but you
know what i mean and like i said a lot
of their beliefs were particularly their
beliefs in free love as in most cult
leaders very self-serving of course
right yeah it's free love is about you
giving me the [ __ ] that's what they're
that's what they're [ __ ] saying yeah
basically what i want yeah basically oh
and don't touch her that's mine yeah you
know that [ __ ] well like i said there's
a massive double standard you see that
in a lot of not so much with these guys
because they didn't really seem to care
enough yeah um
but harem creation and harem sharing but
yeah a lot of the a lot of the [ __ ] and
like i said you see this on a lot of
cult leaders too it's just kind of like
well free love like for me i want to be
able to bang all the chicks i want but
like all these chicks that i'm banging
um you're not allowed to bang any of the
other dudes
[ __ ] your wife that belongs to me
right
so like i said it's very very
double-sided
that was some weird [ __ ] dudes have this
weird like not all dudes obviously but
it's like a dude mentality to be like
well i can do whatever i want but you
can't you know what i mean it's it's
that kind of thing so i kind of feel
like there was an aspect of that
so like i said i can't you know william
godwin like i said that's mary shelley's
dad um yes he was very ahead of his time
yes he was very into free love but uh
that was still his daughter and she was
still 16. uh and that her boyfriend was
still married so he was just kind of
like yeah i don't like this you all
can't see each other uh at this point
percy shelly being a drama queen
uh proposes i believe a suicide pact uh
so he's gonna give mary some poison and
then he's gonna shoot himself uh mary's
like yeah no i don't really i love you
but i'm not gonna do that okay
um and he's just like okay well you
talked me out of it but then he goes
home later and drinks like a whole [ __ ]
ton of lot in him uh which also didn't
kill him
so that's two suicide attempts already
like i said drama queen big time
uh so he decided after the two suicide
attempts failed well
i have to be with mary uh or my life is
over
so we're going to do some [ __ ]
now
so what they decided to do was they're
going to run away together and
essentially a lope they didn't marry
until later i think that's kind of like
a misnomer because when people talk
about the summer of 1816 and they still
call her mary shelley they weren't
technically they weren't married at that
time they didn't marry until later on
so uh so yeah so they decide to run away
together
so in the middle of the night this is
like some [ __ ] up [ __ ] so mary like
sneaks out of the house
uh and percy is like in a coach or
whatever and he's like waiting for her
now this was a big deal because mary
shelley
um her and her dad i mean she loved her
dad she worshipped her dad and
normally if she hadn't been so
what do you want to call it like dick
smacked if she hadn't been so in love
with percy shelley
she probably wouldn't have done this
[ __ ] although i do kind of feel like she
thought that maybe her dad would
understand or that he would forgive her
but that's not really what happened
um which we'll get into in a little bit
but
um so she essentially ran off with percy
shelley
she snuck out in the middle of night and
ran off with him
now interestingly
she brought a a third wheel along with
her
this third wheel
was claire claremont now claire
claremont was her
stepsister
because after barry shelley's mother
mary wollstonecraft had died four years
later um william godwin had remarried
mary's stepmother and mary never got
along
because i think that the stepmother like
had some kids of her own including
claire
and um i kind of feel like mary thought
that this stepmother like favored
the you know her own kids obviously i
mean that happens a lot
so her and mary had a very contentious
relationship
and indeed mary
and her stepsister claire claremont also
seems to have had seem to have had like
a um
a little bit of a contentious relation
they were like frenemies
i don't know that's kind of what i get
from reading about them
um
another thing too was that claire
at least when they first all ran off
together
she was all trying to jump on percy
shelley's dick also which mary was not
having
so they were almost like for the long
time that the three of them like hung
out together
there was a lot of like uh infighting
like jealousy between the two of them so
there's like a lot of sexual tension
going on and like i said percy shelly
being all into like free love being i
can bang whoever i want to and you can't
say boo about it
so he's like trying to get into claire's
pants as well mary's not loving that so
you know so there's a lot of like [ __ ]
going on between the two stepsisters so
that probably wasn't fun either
uh cause one of percy shelley's ideas
like i said was he
one of his dreams
he's gonna set up a commune because of
course he was yeah uh with a harem
essentially he wanted to hear him he
wanted to be a cult leader yeah that's
kind of like that's that's why i made
that comparison
because it really does seem like
you know it sounds cool like you're
advocating for like yeah women can sleep
with whoever they want like yeah that's
awesome
and but oh as long as they all sleep
with me
you can't sleep with other dudes
i'm gonna have it like you can sleep
with who you want as long as it's me
yeah and i kind of feel like this age i
don't think any of the mormon cults had
started yet
so he's coming up with this kind of out
of the blue
yeah i mean it was like i said it was
kind of in like certain circles at that
time it wasn't like unheard of yeah but
it was still very fringe trying to think
of [ __ ] where he's getting this
inspiration
is this just coming up out of nowhere or
is he
or is he inventing this all the time
maybe it's just like a natural thing
well i'm popular and there's all these
women i have to have a justification for
me getting balls deep into all these
women and it's got to be somewhere
outside of society where i control it
like my own little paradise
oh yeah he's going oh yeah i'm sure that
that's exactly what the thought process
was whether it was that
uh cut and dried or whether he was that
aware of it well god's involved in it or
this and that or it's our new world that
we're making yeah okay i i think i see
where it's covered from yeah so it's not
it's not as a revolutionary idea as you
would actually think it's it's just it's
not it's just a natural process
and like i said i had going on in the
middle east and other countries in rome
forever so well yeah and like i said
that's why
like from our point of view like all
this advocation of like free love it
sounds very like yeah that's cool but in
practice i kind of feel like the dudes
that were advocating for it were only
advocating for it as long as all the
women slept with them well of course
that was kind of like the caveat of
because it's like well we don't want
women to be free to bang other dudes
yeah would you make a paradise where the
women are banging some other dudes yes
they often paying me
that's that's how that's gonna work out
yeah yeah because the fantasy falls
apart yeah when it's all these chicks
banging some other dude yeah yeah it's
like oh man that wasn't how i envisioned
this game what happened when i gave when
i gave women the right to like sleep
with whoever they wanted wait a minute i
just assumed they would all jump on my
dick
i didn't think they'd be jumping on
these other [ __ ] i don't like i
don't like that at all let's let's let's
let's we gotta cut this [ __ ] off we
gotta cut this [ __ ] that's exactly like
a new law
you can't [ __ ] anybody unless you're
married
and then they go back to it goes back to
the way it was because that's how that
[ __ ] that's that's how that's how that
cycle [ __ ] started
oh yeah i'm sure i have no doubt at all
about it yet because that's kind of
it seems like all the dudes well at
least all the ones that we know about
nowadays that advocated for free love
absolutely i kind of feel like that was
sort of their attitude yeah i mean it's
hard to say with like percy shelley and
lord byron because they both died so
young but uh you know that's i kind of
feel like if they'd gotten older they
would have got like way more
conservative suddenly it's like suddenly
oh women can't do [ __ ] anymore because
y'all aren't jumping on my dick anymore
now that i'm old i kind of feel like it
would have gone in that direction
so uh so yeah so
mary even though she's only 16 at the
time i mean she was pretty like she's
pretty [ __ ] uh intelligent
she had to know
that
this was gonna be i don't think she
expected her dad to have as drastic uh a
reaction as he did
um but this is like
they weren't you know they weren't
they were kind of wealthy her family
um you know at least you know and they
were kind of like respected in certain
circles so she did have like a rep to
protect i guess if you want to say it
that way so she was kind of like ruining
her reputation in a way
um and maybe risking
alienating herself from her family
although i don't know if she realized
the extent of uh what that would happen
when she actually did it because she was
so
you know just dick struck i guess uh
with percy shelley they were like so in
love or whatever so they run off
together with claire claremont
dick struck i did jenny said dick struck
okay
i mean she's 16. what are you gonna do
uh affected
yeah what easily affected i thought you
said penisley effect
everything's impressive at 16. that's
what i mean everything's like a big
giant deal and you know you so you can
kind of like forgive them a little bit
teenagers do dumb [ __ ] whether it's now
or whether it's like the [ __ ] or
whether it's 1800 whatever
so they run off together and then they
go on this like big adventure type of
thing sort of like they go um they get a
boat and they go across the english
channel there's this big huge storm
they're almost killed it's like this
[ __ ] you know it's this whole thing
um so they end up they going they go to
switzerland like to this resort
and then they go along the rhine river
now apparently um
i've seen this from some sources but
while they're traveling at this stage
mary first heard about a story named uh
this dude who i guess he was a real guy
but he was like an anatomist and his
name was conrad dipple
and he was um like i said he was an
anatomist and he was also kind of like
into the occult and [ __ ] like that and
one thing that he would do allegedly was
that he would steal dead bodies at a
graveyards and he had this like uh serum
or something like that that he had
apparently invented um and injected it
into the dead bodies and brought them
back to life so this is kind of like a
story that she heard well after she had
run away with percy
and this story
of this person um like really fascinated
her
now
this dude's the place where he was born
uh was this place called rock of the
franks which in german is borg
frankenstein so they think that maybe
that's where she got the initial the
kernel of the idea first kind of like
going around in her mind when she's 16
years old because as i said she had
grown up in an era where
galvanism was kind of a big thing people
were like shocking dead bodies and say
we brought him back to life so this was
kind of like a big like the nature of
life
was kind of like on the forefront of
scientific thought at the time and that
was something that seemed to like
fascinate her you know what i mean
so you know so like i said i talked
about uh galvani before luigi galbani
like bringing the [ __ ] frogs
to life or that's what everybody thought
but so you know that that was kind of
like a big thing that was going on uh at
the time
now uh so basically like i said and
there was also she was also fascinated
by
grave robbers because as we mentioned
earlier
for a long time and during this period
you weren't allowed
even if you were in medical school this
is so [ __ ] up if you're in medical
school you weren't allowed to dissect
corpses right
because it was considered like i guess
like sacrilegious or you were you know
you were blaspheming the dead or
whatever
so there was kind of like a huge
underground trade in
uh corpses that people would dig up and
they'd sell to medical schools like get
rich back in the day you got a day off
doing that [ __ ] like i said broken hair
track of the day
just sell some dead bodies burke and
hair probably the most famous but um you
know because they started killing people
and i'm sure some other ones did as well
i'm sure it was probably actually pretty
commonplace but there was a very
bustling like black market in corpses
because obviously you're in medical
school you're going to be a doctor
you're going to be cutting into living
people
probably it's a good idea to like cut up
some cadavers and like see what the
[ __ ] going on in there instead of just
like some [ __ ] drawings from
you know the ancient greeks which might
or might not be entirely anatomically
accurate so you know uh so there was a
demand so obviously a black market
supply had risen up to
meet that demand and uh that was another
thing that mary was fascinated by was
like kind of grave robbing or all that
kind of uh you know cadaver [ __ ] that
was going on uh back then
so
so basically all right so mary they
could they kind of went on the run for a
while
and then in 1814
uh she comes back to london
with
uh percy
and she is
pregnant she's got a bun in the oven
she's tubbed as they say in the uk
now she comes back to her dad's house
fully expecting him to be cool with it
uh but well like i said her and her dad
were like quite close um and because he
was such an advocate of like free love
he was very into life so
he she thought that he would understand
um
he did not
uh william godwin basically was like no
get the [ __ ] out of my sight
um
you know this is not this is not cool
they did reconcile later spoiler alert
but uh for a time period uh basically he
was so mad that he's like i don't even
want to look at you right now because
you ran off
with a married man after i told you not
to
uh and got yourself pregnant and i am
just like not having it right now
you know i thought i raised you better
it was this whole thing
now
yeah so at this point mary is only 17
years old
and she uh so she's pregnant she gives
birth to the baby two months prematurely
and the baby
died damn now after this
she had horrible recurring nightmares
about this dead baby
uh which sadly and again spoiler alert
this is not the first dead baby that was
a lot of her babies died i'm just saying
that's so it's [ __ ] up
uh so yeah so she's very young she's
only 17 and she has a dead baby and she
keeps having like nightmares about it
uh which might have been why she was so
fascinated by
stories about people trying to bring the
dead back to life maybe i'm just
speculating
uh but she was really [ __ ] up
by her baby dying which understandably
so
now it's kind of like at this point
because i guess because mary's baby has
died
and again understandably
she's uh
not happy she's depressed
um you know she's not going to be real
fun to be around
and you would think well i wouldn't
think this but you would think that
percy her
boyfriend would be supportive you know
oh it's terrible our baby died it's you
know it's worse and you would think that
he would like try to support her through
this difficult time
but
not so much uh it does really seem like
percy was kind of more like well i'm
gonna go hang out with claire
because she's a little bit younger
uh she's not a bummer all the time
because her baby died that's not i'm you
know i'm paraphrasing i don't know if he
actually said any of these things but
his attitudes at the time do kind of
like uh do kind of suggest this
um so he's basically like hanging out
with claire moore because she i guess
she was more fun and like i said she was
younger and she didn't have this
crushing
grief that mary was going through that
percy really didn't seem all that uh
willing to deal with uh he was pretty
young too gotta say
now
percy shelley uh he was actually from a
wealthy family i believe his dad was a
baronet
but
uh because he had run off he had
abandoned his wife and kids
and had run off with a 16 year old girl
which back then like i said probably a
little more acceptable but still not all
that acceptable so his wealthy family
were like okay percy you were cut off
so he was really not like every now and
then if he really begged like his dad
would give him like some money but he
wasn't getting i guess he was getting
like a yearly stipend before and he
wasn't getting that anymore because they
did not approve
of the [ __ ] that he was up to
so
uh so during this time period not only
was mary grieving her you know her first
child being dead
uh and also pro possibly losing her
lover's attentions to another woman
uh also then they had to deal with a
bunch of [ __ ] poverty because now
suddenly uh you know percy's family had
cut him off and they didn't have like a
lot of money to live on anymore
now
i'm going to have to uh go to the
bathroom yeah yeah you got drinks and
stuff like that you just carry you can
use mine if you need to
okay okay i'm just gonna go in here
all right
talk about something
i am talking she tells me to talk about
something
talk about what i see what let's see
what the comments say
all right um
mango says he has to check out because
he's got an early showing of dune
tomorrow take night off and take care of
yeah um
um con of iceland over in mexico
got a uh
a uh hd
copy a bootleg copy of dune
and he saw he said it was great he liked
it
he um his wife didn't like it as much he
his wife thought it was more of like
kind of like a man's movie you know what
i mean so i'm like okay then it's gonna
be all mine i [ __ ] love the original
the david lynch version and all the um
the games
but the dune emperor i still i have a pc
that only has one purpose and that's to
play dune emperor
if you guys know that game i [ __ ]
love it the music and everything i'll go
in there and lift to the harkonnen
soundtrack
had a great music it was like it's late
90s
it's kind of like uh
it's kind of like a predecessor of
[ __ ] what's it even
like red alert i think it's the name of
the uh
of that series
i [ __ ] loved it
anyway she's back what are you talking
about
talking about um dune
oh okay
we gotta see that yeah khan got a uh
bootleg hd bootleg copy of it watched it
at home he thought he liked it his wife
didn't like it as much though i'm
excited yeah he said it's good
and of course it's not the whole movie
it's going to be a trilogy but that's
great that's the only way you're going
to be able to [ __ ]
talk about dude and i like we liked that
director
so yeah like i said he did blade runner
20 40. we gotta see maybe tomorrow we'll
see halloween
yeah i kind of wanted because like i
said we were trying to go see it earlier
in the week but there weren't any early
shows and i just didn't have time to go
so maybe we'll go tomorrow because we're
not streaming tomorrow jenny's trimming
back down those [ __ ] titties are
looking [ __ ] grabbing i'm gonna grab
one of them [ __ ] and then her legs
jenny been working those legs out
they're looking good
yeah i got something got my bike jenny's
making a comeback i'm gonna get you on
that leg extension machine that other
one too the [ __ ] that'll accelerate
it even more
jenny making a comeback
where we're coming back from where where
was i i don't know where you were you
went somewhere for a few months no i
didn't okay i didn't go anywhere right
here all right
[Laughter]
well we both put on some weight well we
did yeah but that's i mean that's
because your food is so good yeah and we
had to [ __ ] go into that [ __ ] so
and you stopped making such delicious
fattening food well i did
you did i know i did
and during this move i [ __ ] trimmed
down quite a bit
well because we were busy and we weren't
eating and we were just like working all
day because we were just like carrying
[ __ ] up and down stairs up and down
stairs up and down stairs like all day
and we weren't really stopping to eat we
like we would go into town we wouldn't
even hungry i wouldn't even get hungry
yeah well we weren't thinking about it
you we'd go an entire day and like not
eat anything and be like oh yeah we
forgot to eat because we were so [ __ ]
busy yeah but you know i forget to eat
sometimes too when i'm like i just kept
injecting testosterone and taking
antivirus [ __ ] just getting more and
more powerful more tired i get the
stronger i'd get that's some weird [ __ ]
yeah
so uh while you were gone i was talking
about
uh because mary shelley's first baby had
died uh and percy was just kind of like
okay well you're a bummer to be around
now because you're grieving so i'm gonna
go hang out with claire so obviously
that didn't really uh help mary's mental
state any
uh and also
percy shelley's uh parents who were kind
of like nobility they uh cut him off
because he was married he abandoned his
wife and kids and had run off with a 16
year old girl and they were not happy
about it so they're basically like well
you're not getting your [ __ ]
allowance anymore
bye [ __ ] so uh so there was also some
poverty they had to deal with so again
kind of a shitty situation
so uh so basically
uh less than a year later
uh you know mary was pregnant again
and um she uh actually had a son
named william uh he was born when she
was 18 years old and she
adored this kid
now
at this point like i said percy was kind
of he's kind of trying to split the
difference between mary and claire at
this point no one's entirely sure if he
was [ __ ] clear at this point i'm
pretty sure he probably was probably
[ __ ] every woman that he was around uh
i imagine he did yeah um a rock star
type [ __ ] yeah mentality yeah he
couldn't keep it in his pants i'm pretty
sure probably had a lot of women who
were just were trying to get some of
that just just to get the name
yeah just to see what it was all about i
mean he wasn't super famous at this time
it's ironic because i kind of feel like
for a time mary shelley was a little bit
overshadowed by percy but percy shelley
arguably would not be remembered uh
as much as he was if it wasn't for mary
pushing to have his poems like published
and [ __ ] like that after he died because
he died real young
so he was known at the time
but he wasn't like
famous famous right he wasn't as famous
as lord byron i think he was more famous
because he was like associated with the
[ __ ] man your name is [ __ ] your name
has the title lord on the front of it
yeah back in the day when that was some
[ __ ] you know what i mean well his
actual name was george gordon yeah
and lord byron that's george gordon
comma that's my famous [ __ ] right there
and he was more fit he was more infamous
than famous
had some fancy [ __ ] because he was such
a oh yeah he's a hoe yeah well not only
a hoe but he was like kind of he was the
worst kind of hoe he's just like i'm
just gonna impregnate all these women
and then be like yeah [ __ ] your kids
yeah right i'm not supporting that's
your problem yeah that's well
essentially yeah he did not care at all
he did not care got pregnant and percy
had a little bit of that going on too
not as bad as lord byron i will say um
at least percy did seem to care
a little bit but lord byron absolutely
did not care he really did not he just
like put his dick everywhere and like
just let the chips fall where they may
he really did not give a [ __ ] uh so yeah
he was kind of a terrible person but uh
yeah so there was that there that whole
thing
so
uh so yeah so at this point uh you know
mary's had another kid william so that's
kind of like cheered her up some because
you know william was apparently a
delightful little boy
uh claire like i said probably [ __ ]
percy at this time too no one's entirely
sure but i'm i'm imagining probably they
were
uh now
1815 though claire took off uh and she
because she was they were all living in
one room essentially like a studio
apartment type situation uh so she
[ __ ] off and went to devon and she was
also pregnant at this time too and she
gave birth to a baby was it percy's
probably uh no one can prove that
but
you know uh it was kind of common back
in those days for a pregnant woman who
was not married to kind of like
disappear for a time and go like oh i
was convalescing i had a disease or
something because it was like you know
the shame of like having birth out of
wedlock so you have special facilities
for this yes you had to like disappear
for a while and then come back and be
like oh hi i'm back it's like oh i was
so sick for like yeah but everybody kind
of knew what the deal was yeah and the
baby i guess got
sold out to adoption or something yeah
they put them like in orphanages or send
them to a convent or some [ __ ] like that
it's like [ __ ] yeah um so yeah so
they think that claire like
disappeared for a time and gave birth to
a baby possibly percy's allegedly nobody
knows uh but probably
uh but then she comes back like nothing
happened right
uh now at this point she comes back and
she's like well percy shelley
is fine and all but i got my eyes on
some bigger game
i'm gonna go after lord byron
right
although i kind of feel like bigger game
yeah because he was like more famous and
stuff but was it easy to get lord byron
to [ __ ] you and absolutely it was easy
to get lord byron to [ __ ] you all you'd
have to do is just like come up to the
dude and be like hey i'm a woman and
he'd be like all right i'm [ __ ] that
[ __ ] so it's like it's not like a big
achievement to get lord byron to [ __ ]
you he'd [ __ ] everybody that was kind of
his thing
um so so you know if you were like a
good-looking woman he was yeah he was
getting yeah i got him he was gonna get
in there but like i said it's
he wasn't going to
give a [ __ ] about you or
if you got pregnant he wasn't you like a
roller coaster
yeah and then he was like okay you did
it he must be the stall to ride and yeah
and then but after that he'd be like
okay bye now it's gonna be the end of it
so you know
i don't know why you men like that
throughout history but a lot of men like
that they exist right now like that
well yeah i mean it's easy for them they
don't really have to bear the brunt of
i mean they don't have to like get fat
for nine months and have a kid that's
gonna like [ __ ] be the average dude
is like that well i know they are yeah
yeah why why do you think i'm so cynical
about the whole thing
you know you know who i am
well that's why it's because they i mean
they don't have to really suffer a lot
of consequences
uh in the same way that a woman does you
know what i'm saying
and you can see that i mean particularly
in this time period it's probably better
nowadays but back then
i don't really think anybody expected i
mean nobody expected men to be involved
in any kind of child care or anything
like that you fathered children left and
right and they'd just be like oh well
not my problem yeah they should be going
on for centuries that's what i mean not
my problem i'm really not knocking
knocking knocking down all the peasant
women and they're having kids look man
i'm gonna do with it not to do with that
[ __ ] not my problem
it wasn't their problem
it wasn't their problem she should have
kept her legs closed
yeah it's like well you know what was
gonna happen he let me have you know she
she let me have sex with her so she must
have been okay with like how that was
gonna work out you know what i mean yeah
so uh so yeah
now lord byron as i said at this time
even in this time
uh
yeah but he's pretty uh very rock star
kind of reputation depending on who was
talking about like some people thought
he was awesome but like most people just
kind of thought he was like a [ __ ]
debauched
uh piece of [ __ ] you know what i mean
um
he was kind of like
he was basically one of those dudes that
he just lived by his creed i guess he
just like did whatever the [ __ ] he
wanted
one of the most famous quotes about him
the description of mad bad and dangerous
to know that's what they called him uh
because like i said you couldn't have
boobs or a vagina around the dude he
would like knock it down and then like
he'd knock you up and then just be like
bye
you know and just move on to the next
one
um also maybe
allegedly uh probably he had sex with
his half-sister so you know well that's
not i don't think that was a little
weird but okay i don't think that was
really a big deal back then i mean
[ __ ] uh mary shelley [ __ ] wrote
some [ __ ] about her dad
she didn't really know her dad that well
and she was just saying that she was
just really interested in that dude
whenever he was around just she called
him that man a lot she was actually
really close to her dad yeah like i said
they had a big rift after she ran off
with percy but they they uh reconciled
it i don't know how old she was when she
was writing that i think she was 15 or
16 when she was calling him that man
hmm
and well she was 16 when she ran off
with percy okay so it might have it
might have been a little bit and then
for many years uh her dad wouldn't speak
to her because of that okay uh they
reconciled later when she married percy
yeah like in 1816 i was uh so for a
couple years they were like i saw the
clothes reading about her
in a textbook one time they had i had to
do a [ __ ] literature english lit
and uh
or american literature one of the two
remember which one well it'd be english
wouldn't it yeah english yeah and um
no it was kind of inferred that there
might have been something going on there
between her and her dad at least on her
side that she was in love with him
although it's not that weird though
because i kind of feel like
well i don't know i don't know how
common it is but i think
i don't know there there's kind of thing
for like young girls to be like
idolize their dad in some ways
i don't i didn't do that but he was gone
she was saying he was gone all the time
and he would show up she was just
talking about that man that mysterious
man and [ __ ] just going on it
somebody could probably dig up the
quotes it just kind of kind of sounded
suspicious
but you know but the thing about it
though is that we're seeing things
through a modern lens and it's like
maybe because the thing about it and i
was just i don't know why i just thought
of this but um
in the victorian era particularly
the way that men would write to their
close friends
to us
it sounds like
yeah yeah yeah yeah um but it wasn't
like not back in the day not really yeah
um but they were just a lot more they
were just like different in the way they
expressed their emotions toward one
another like i'd feel like it was real
flower length really yeah that's what i
mean so it might have been a case of
that where just we're seeing things
through modern sensibilities and it's
like whoa that sounds like really weird
but back then it wouldn't have been
weird i don't know i i don't know i
don't i haven't read that so i'm not
really sure she refers to him as that
man
but that's not that's not i mean that
really doesn't suggest anything i just
thought it was weird
and then she was just curious and this
and that and [ __ ] how he was gone and
now he's back and it's like
it's been a long time you have to think
too that she i mean her mother died when
she was a baby right so she had been
raised by her dad and presumably like
servants or nannies or whatever because
i don't think like a man would raise a
baby back then
but um not not somebody of his status
but um
so maybe she just thought of him as this
kind of like
maybe she idolized him yeah because he
was i mean his followers and stuff like
that like he had like acolytes and
whatever and they actually did like um
idolize him at the time so maybe that's
how she thought of him she thought him
was maybe like this god like
sort of figure because like i said i
kind of feel like they
had been really close during her
childhood because they shared a lot of
the same attitudes their personality was
very similar which i think was why when
she ran off with percy shelly
why she was so surprised
when she came back to london and her dad
would not speak to her i don't i think
that was very
upsetting for her because she expected
that her dad would understand
and she was very very shocked that he
did not because basically she was like
well that's kind of like your whole
thing right it's like free love and like
i'm you know we're allowed to do
whatever we want it's like we're
following our heart it's individualist
blah blah so i kind of feel like
you know in her 16 year old mind she's
like well i'm doing exactly what you
always advocated so why are you [ __ ]
on me so i kind of you know i'm putting
words in her mouth obviously but i kind
of feel like that was the attitude she
was coming at it with and so she didn't
really get why he was so mad at her you
know what i mean i think she thought
that he would understand and he didn't
uh but like i said he's still a dad and
that's still his daughter
people aren't saying much
bee's nest said the fbi believes that
they found brian laundry's remains he
offered himself i don't know who that is
oh yeah somebody was asking me about
some kind of game some kind of yeah like
a disappearance yeah somebody asked me
about it because i said oh we should do
a show about that one these days uh but
yeah so we're talking about uh lord
byron so if y'all want to send us some
of them flash bulbs now would be a good
time to get some of them super chats
where they have it
so you're working her heart out
well this i love this this all this kind
of [ __ ] i love this literary [ __ ] yeah
like i know like tom makes fun of me
for being
for overthinking things and being
interested in these kind of like
high-minded that's what he's called back
and stuff um i know he makes fun of me
for being into that but it's like i'm
into that and it's like sorry
i'm sorry not sorry no i'm not sorry
she's not sorry no i just saw it just
switch just different tastes that's all
yeah i'm just like super i'm really into
this i was like i love this kind of [ __ ]